this is Jocko podcast number 261 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink good
evening Echo good evening
being in the teams
is the best job in the world
probably heard me say that before the
best job in the world why do I say that
why do I say that well first of all the
job itself
which consists of
shooting machine guns
jumping out of airplanes blowing things
up
scuba diving
running around in the woods
it's just a freaking awesome job
so so you got that on top of that you
got this mission
the mission that you're focused on
you're on a mission to protect America
to protect democracy to protect freedom
to protect
people
and in order to do that kill bad guys
because you're supposed to do all that
protecting in order to do all that
protecting you got to kill bad guys
which
as a kid and really as a man for that
matter that's what me and my friends
always wanted to do and I'm sorry if
that doesn't sit right with you
or if you think I'm some kind of a
monster because of it but that
that's the reality
so that's another reason why the job is
awesome but the last thing and certainly
not the least thing
in fact
the best thing about the job by far
is the boys
the boys the guys you get to work with
they're they're awesome and contrary to
popular belief there's no cookie cutter
format that represents a guy in the SEAL
Teams
the guys come in all shapes and sizes
they come from all different backgrounds
and it should be noted that not all of
them
are good guys there are some
Knuckleheads for sure there's some
egomaniacs there's some guys that really
aren't part of the team there's some
guys that look out for themselves
there's guys that don't help out there's
some guys that don't care about the
mission
those guys that put themselves above the
team
so there's there's some of those
types running around and that's true in
any organization but as a whole
the boys are pretty legit
they're hard working they're tough they
put the team first
to get the mission done
and they have fun while they're doing it
and you can count on them
which is an underrated thing right you
can count on them
and I was lucky enough to work with a
ton of those guys during my career
I was
leaving ramadi so it's the end of my
last deployment
and I was leaving ramadi and another
task unit came in to take our place and
they were coming into a complete and
utter firestorm
of sustained combat
and look we had all been deploying a
bunch
over the years since 9 11 and this was
2006.
sort of the end of 2006 and so so guys
knew what it was like to go on combat
deployments
but
this particular combat deployment that
we had been on in the Battle of ramadi
was significant we had a lot of
casualties
and
these guys that were coming to replace
us
I mean I knew that they were coming into
something that
seals hadn't deployed into in a long
time and look I'm not saying that seals
weren't deploying into dangerous places
they were but kind of a known
scenario like that it'd been a while
and so
I felt
horrible actually
I felt horrible for the new task unit
that was showing up to replace us
because I felt like we had learned so
much there and we had gotten good at our
jobs and we I felt like we were leaving
this other task unit in a bad spot
and
I was worried
about them and worried how they would
survive
foreign
well I knew a few other guys
a few other guys I knew and and that
gave me a level of comfort one of the
guys that I knew was the senior enlisted
guy of the task unit a guy named Steve
Ward
one of one of the good guys and I I kind
of knew him tangently over the years
because I had turned I turned over with
him in Baghdad a couple years earlier
he'd been in the leadership position in
a platoon a team five and to run a bunch
of operations and done a great job and
I'd gotten a solid turnover from him so
that was awesome
it just made my comfort level go up that
someone
was coming in that was
humble enough to listen and learn not
just from me not just from tasking a
Bruiser but also from the Army in the
Marine Corps and who is also smart
enough and knowledgeable enough
to mix in that knowledge and that
experience with humility and make sense
of the whole crazy situation
which is what he did and
when Steve came back from that
deployment which which was a hard
deployment for them we ended up working
together actually actually truly working
together for the first time at trade at
the training command
he took over the land Warfare training
cell as the senior enlisted advisor in
that training block and we ended up
spending spending a lot of time together
training and preparing seals for combat
deployments to Iraq and Afghanistan
and it was a
it
I I it's hard for me to even say it was
a challenging job yeah it was a
challenging job but
it was so critical and it was so
rewarding
to be able to work with the young frog
man and pass on the lessons learned to
the Next Generation
so that they could go out there
and take the fight to the enemy
and keep themselves safe as safe as they
possibly could
and I eventually retired out of that job
and Steve carried on in his career he
went on to more senior positions of
leadership and continue to deploy over
and over again in support of the war on
terror
until
a few months ago when he finally retired
and since then we've been working
together again still
still actually training leaders this
time for leadership in the business
world
but we're back at it and it is an honor
to be working with Steve again and it is
an honor to have Steve here on the
podcast to tell us about his life his
experiences and his lessons learned
Steve thanks for coming on Matt hey
thanks for having me I appreciate it
choco
you were one of the guys in the
beginning when this podcast kind of
kicked off that was giving me reports
from the field that you were in the game
listening to it yeah me and Gardner were
going back and forth you know in some of
the book you covered early on like the
last hundred yards I was like damn how
can you not get on the net and listen to
that for you know a couple hours so it
was good yeah and here you are sitting
in the sitting in the chair uh let's go
let's let's rock and roll let's talk
about where Steve Ward came from yep so
grew up in Sacramento California small
town
um my mom and dad were divorced so I'd
go see my dad in the in the summer
months and my sister and my mom and I we
all grew up together in Sacramento
um I graduated high school in 91. slow
your roll bro yeah so we got a list to
cover man come on so what did you what'd
your mom do what'd your mom do for a
living so she worked at a Davis College
she was like an administrator there and
then what about your dad where was your
dad so my dad he was an air traffic
controller so he kind of bounced around
the U.S spent a lot of time in Florida
Puerto Rico uh up in Washington so did
you see much of your dad growing up yeah
in the summertime me and my sister go
out and see him for anywhere from two
weeks to 30 days at a time it's always
good well it's good as it could be so
you just Breeze through like oh went to
high school and then graduated you were
about to like be in the Navy well did
you play sports yes so played a baseball
soccer and football coming up any good
I'd say I was an average athlete nothing
special I wasn't consistent I had good
like for baseball I had times when I was
doing good and then I'd get in a slump
and wouldn't do so good slump due to
bad attitude slump from
um I'm trying to think of a good way to
word this here slump from not I guess
being good enough you know like you get
so I was a pitcher I played baseball I
played pitcher and I played Outfield and
I'd have some times where I'd get up
there and you know my friends would be
cracking jokes at me you're gonna be in
the first batter you're going to beam
the first batter first pitch I'd be in
the first battle I'm like damn you know
you're not you can't correct crack jokes
up on the mound because you just hit
somebody with a baseball so you know
didn't pan out too good for me so my
junior year I kind of quit baseball and
my freshman year I started playing
football and I really enjoyed football
contact sport hard like a lot of hard
work goes into that so I enjoyed
football finished that up my you know
senior year I played all four years
um in soccer I kind of quit playing that
when I was probably like around 13 14
years old what kind of what what were
your friends doing when you weren't
playing sports
get in trouble getting in trouble so
Sports
you know I was probably like uh
I wouldn't say a bad kid but I was
definitely off the path seventh eighth
and Ninth Grade not good things for me
you know I got I was picking up trash on
the side of the roads I was on probation
just doing stupid [__] for what just
nothing I cared repeated
just uh what do they call that
delinquent delinquent I was a delinquent
and it wasn't my friends it was me I was
a guy that was like one of when my
friends came around I was a guy
instigating and kind of leading the
charge on doing what kind of music were
you listening to yeah just whatever like
country rap rock it didn't matter just
didn't matter we had the old AM FM
radios there ain't nothing going on yeah
there's a different time yeah you were
limited to what you could actually hear
yeah was it a small town
um yeah so I grew up actually in West
Sac it was definitely a small town okay
and uh so yeah small town smaller high
school I went to a high school called
River City
um that was small did they have
wrestling there they had they started a
wrestling program I think when I was in
about 10th grade there I didn't I didn't
wrestle I played football and I didn't I
stayed away from basketball
um
yeah how was your grades
eventually not good not they were not
good I passed High School by the you
know barely passed high school so it
wasn't good for me I didn't pay
attention had good teachers always
giving you good advice I was just not
into learning so you're a little bit of
a troublemaker right do you think when
you were being a troublemaker do you
think you were doing it for attention do
you think you were doing it for the
thrill do you think you were doing it
for adrenaline like why do you think you
were doing it I I think when I was a
truck which I was yeah I think of a lot
of it what I was doing to sort of prove
to myself and my friends that I was like
uh uh
tough like type things like I don't care
I'll do this like that kind of thing
when I think back
as to why I did dumb [__] which I did
plenty of I think that's why a lot of it
was like to prove
that I was a quote and I'm putting in
Big Air quotes here tough because the
stuff I was doing was by no stretch of
the imagination tough yep I'd say I fall
in that same category trying to prove
something just doing and I got a journal
adrenaline rush out of doing those dumb
things
and it took a long time to get out of my
system
so you said that was mostly sixth
seventh eighth ninth grade seventh
eighth and Ninth Yeah by 10th grade were
you kind of a little bit more squared
away turn in the corner yes yep did you
feel did you have some run-ins with the
law that kind of straightened you back
out
probation and picking up trash on the
side of the road kind of squared me away
real quick You Gotta Wear the little
orange vest if you're in the van with
all the rest of the delinquents you're
on the road on Saturday and Sundays not
a not a good situation
not a good situation so then you you
graduate you barely graduate high school
at what point did you think about
joining the Navy or did you think about
the joining the Marine Corps or the Army
where where did you what was the
situation with enlisting in the military
so I remember one of our my high school
teachers told me hey you got three
choices when you get out of high school
and he's kind of mentoring us and none
of us know it at the time but he's like
hey you can go to college which I highly
recommend you can get a job or you can
join the military or you can do a
combination of one and two
and that kind of always stuck with me
you know and then as I started going to
college like man I just I don't want to
learn I wasn't ready to learn wait a
second so you just skipped
right to you're in college so you when
you when you're still in high school you
you didn't join the Navy or join the
military while you're in high school
correct he gave you the three options
job College military you chose College
yes first yep you thought all right did
you have any freaking vision of any kind
whatsoever you're just like no sign up
for whatever classes they signed me up
for yeah so I just signed up for the
basic general education stuff you know
went for a full semester and then dove
into the second semester and that's
where like at one point I don't even
know how the recruiter wound up at our
door but the recruiter wound up on our
doorstep and I started talking to him
and where's the doorstep of what your
house
of the house so you know you go through
and I was like yeah this is something I
think I might be interested because your
mom called the damn recruiter and sent
him oh she was kicking him out of there
oh really she was not having any other
recruiter she told him get the hell out
of here was your mom a hippie or
something no no she's a farm girl she
grew up on a farm yeah she just didn't
she didn't want me joining the military
but you talk to him I talked to him and
was he a navy recruiter Navy guy yep
Navy recruiter did you have any inkling
did you have any parents grandparents
anything about the military yeah you
understood yeah so my grandfather was in
the Army and he was he never went he was
around the World War II era but he never
went and served you know he got
stationed out uh in Alaska somewhere and
then my dad was in the Air Force so I
had some small touch points there with
some cool stories of you know
grandfather being the military we talked
about throwing his grenade and the
sergeant was telling him that was the
best throw ever type thing and then my
dad was in the Air Force
your grandfather was getting told you're
going to beam the batter with that Grace
yeah
so then so the guy took the recruiter
talks to you and at this point you
realize college is like a waste of your
time
yes I'm done with school with school I
didn't enjoy high school and I
definitely wasn't enjoying college at
that point which college was it I was
just called Sac City Community College
so you're and you were so you were
living at home during this time yes yep
living at home working part-time going
to college what was your part-time job
man I don't remember what it was I had a
couple jobs growing up like I worked in
a bunch of different little restaurants
being a busboy being a dishwasher moved
furniture with a guy named Craig who's a
great Family Guy and so we'd get on the
road he worked for Allied furniture and
we'd be trucking on down to LA with
furniture on the back of his big old
18-wheeler it was actually a good job it
was hard work but it paid good money I
was paying 10 bucks an hour back then
that was that was good money you were
kind of the man with 10 bucks an hour
where's the man with 10 bucks an hour
yeah and that was a lot better pay than
the Navy paid you I'll tell you that
back then so how'd the Navy recruiter
convince you he was just like hey come
in and give this a go man and you know
so I went through did all the ASVAB
testing he's like all right we can get
you in uh in June time frame and what
what job were you signing up for because
you didn't enlist did you know about the
seals at this point no I didn't I never
I didn't know what a seal was so I just
I was signing up to go to the regular
Navy to go on a ship to figure life out
yep
little did I know I was about to get
after some bathroom cleaning
so so what what like job did he sell you
on
he didn't sell me he was just like I
mean so I had I grew up with some
friends and they you know a lot of
people were getting in trouble people
were doing drugs all that kind of dumb
stuff so I just knew I had the best
option for me at that point in my life
was to get out of Sacramento and go try
something different so the job I would I
didn't know what I wanted to do did you
go to did you go UD undesignated yes oh
damn yeah so I wasn't you know so for
people that don't know like in the Navy
you have a job it's called your raiding
and your job is you know you might be a
welder you might be a technician or an
engine man that's gonna work on engines
or you might run a weapon system and
they have names for all these different
jobs
but if you don't have a job they call it
and I remember this from boot camp it
was a threat
they'd say yeah you keep this up you're
gonna go to the fleet
UD
undesignated which means you have no job
no skill you're just gonna go in there
so that threat that I got told
was actually what you got signed up for
go to the fleet
UD undesignated sign me up I'm ready to
roll get me out of stock yeah get me out
of here so you rolled into boot camp yup
rolling a boot camp finished up in uh I
want to say right around October time
frame so went to boot camp when did you
go to boot camp in July 1991 okay and
then
would you go to Orlando no no here in
San Diego oh you went to San Diego
that's right West Coast so you went you
went to boot camp and you just went to
boot camp eight weeks it was eight weeks
I think a week so you went to eight
weeks of boot camp and then to the fleet
oh yeah eight weeks of boot camp then I
went to seaman training because I was
going to work in deck Department that
was my own designated I was gonna be you
know uh semen so got trained up for
three weeks there and then showed up to
a ship sometime in I think November
December time frame of 91. bro yeah
[Music]
That's crazy dude yeah that's crazy you
must have done good on your asvabs
that guy didn't try and make you into
like whatever some other rates we could
get more no that's crazy dude well
that's in so that was probably my first
lesson learned in life hey pay attention
at school so you score good on your
ASVAB so you have options right hey when
you're in high school you don't I didn't
ever really thought about that hey I
just need to make it through but yeah
in life you're going to be given some
tests whether you're going to go work in
a fire department a police department
you're going to go in the military and
so the better educated you are the more
options you're going to have available
to and I didn't do so good so my options
were limited
yeah that's one thing I was trying to
explain when like parents ask me about
kids and like what and I think one of
the biggest
things you can do for a kid besides
getting them into Jiu Jitsu is making
them realize that their actions today
have impact on the rest of their life
because we get little kids and when I
say little kids I'm talking me when I
was 23 right what I'm doing right now is
going to impact where I'm going to be
right and so how can you expect a 13
year old or a 15 year old
and you know girls might be a little bit
smarter than boys
it's possible it seems judging from my
own children anyways let me let me let
me rephrase that because I don't want to
generalize in my personal family it
seems like my daughters are a little
better at connecting
and what they're doing right now with
the future than my son who just
doesn't do it as much
so yeah that's a good point when you
realize that what I'm doing right now as
a kid
and it's not just kids what I'm doing
right now as a human is going to impact
the way my life goes yeah and you might
end up in the fleet UD
getting after it so so you do eight
weeks of boot camp three weeks of
preps semen prep school and then boom
you go to a ship yep what was that
wake-up call like
it wasn't bad it wasn't bad it was
probably one of the best things that
ever happened to me what in what way
yeah I just it was it was a lot of hard
work you know it's when you show up in
deck department and you're an E2 you're
getting every you know uh
you're getting all the assignments that
are not fun to do you know you're
cleaning bathrooms you're painting the
ship you're chipping paint off the ship
you're you're just doing all the things
on ship maintenance and so you're eating
some Humble Pie for breakfast lunch and
dinner while you're doing this gave me a
chance to to kind of grow up a little
bit it was good it was hard work
roll the sleeves up and get dirty yeah
you had you had time to reflect yeah
time to reflect what were you thinking
about when you reflecting I was so when
I'm reflecting on it I'm just like hey
man can you make the best out of this
situation so I had one of my buddies
that I uh I went through boot camp with
we wound up on the same ship Chris and
me and him just always had competition
we got put in the same deck department
and every assignment they gave us we're
like running up and down them stairwell
ladders just oh dang compete you know
completing assignments coming back like
hey what else do you got from me like
hey you Knuckleheads that supposed to
take you to lunchtime we're like well
we're done give us more that's awesome
man so um it was it was fun we made the
best of it you know and we had some good
some good leadership on the ship and
some bad leadership you got a that was
my first exposure to kind of what right
looks like what bad leadership looks
like
um so it was good and you're taking down
all these data points and you're storing
it in your head you know
um
and probably one of the biggest things I
took out of that assignment
is we had guys that were super
knowledgeable just very good like we had
a bm2 and he was super good at it being
a bosomate he knew everything how to tie
all the ropes all the maintenance he
knew everything and he was squared away
hard worker looked out for his guys are
like that's a dude I want to be like
um you'd always talk about Echelon front
hate modeling the correct behaviors that
dude was modeling all the right
behaviors busted his ass did good things
and he was getting promoted while I was
on that ship so you're like ah data
point that's what rat looks like same
thing with the handful of chiefs that
were on that ship just good solid dudes
they weren't afraid to roll their
sleeves up get in there with the guys
and get to work and like all right check
mental note on that
so then how long how long was it when
you were in the fleet until you heard
about the teams yeah so we had a couple
guys that didn't make it through SEAL
training they showed up
um came friends with those guys at some
point and they told me all about you
know basic underwater demolition till
training and I was like damn that's
something I'm interested in so I started
training up they told me kind of all the
things you need to do to be successful
they took me over the obstacle course uh
showed me all the tricks on how to
navigate that thing a lot of technique
um in the meantime I was getting my
application together and submitting
everything so when I hit the two-year
mark on the ship I'd had my application
back I was approved to go to to Seal
training and everything was dialed in as
tight as it could be no matter what I
was gonna have to do two years on that
ship
so you weren't even close to your two
years yet and you already had your
application in I would say I had it in
right around the
probably 13 14 month cycle so you owed
whatever whatever those months were
another year or something like that 10
months left yep yep something like that
before they'd release you yeah and the
cool thing was you know we had two my uh
division Master Chief was in E9
obviously he was a good dude and then
our CMC our Command Master Chief of the
of the ship was a good guy and they're
like hey man you work hard you stay out
of trouble we'll make some phone calls
we'll make sure that you get a shot at
going to Buds and they didn't have to do
that you know they could have been like
hey Pac Sand Jack you want to get off
the ship ship get out of the fleet and
go to some other program that's not
helping us out they didn't do that they
looked out for me you know working hard
staying out of trouble being a good
person all those three things were were
good you know so again it was kind of
like reinforcing good behaviors
um so always be thankful to those guys
and then uh the guys the the guys that
showed up that had been to buds what
kind of impression did that give you did
you because there's a weird thing that
somehow you have to think that you can
actually do it right yeah or you know
like for me I was like oh I can do this
which is a really arrogant thing to
think right it's arrogant to think most
people quit but I'm gonna be able to do
it yeah
I wasn't sure where I was going to shake
out on the whole thing to be honest with
you I didn't like run long distance and
grown up you know we did a lot of
Sprints and football
um and I wasn't good with pull-ups that
so pull-ups I was I definitely sucked
that and I was like I don't know if I'm
going to be able to do the amount of
pull-ups that are needed done so I just
started working hard on my pull-ups got
on a good running program got on a good
swimming program those guys taught me
how to do the side stroke and so you
know I just get up early in the morning
knock all this stuff out go in and
either do a weightlifting program and
then do my cardio at lunchtime or vice
versa and uh every now and then those
guys will come over and be like hey dial
this in work on this look at that
um so I was I was mentally and
physically prepared for first phase on
what to expect because these guys have
given me so much information
um did those guys talk about what
happened to them
yeah so one of the two of the guys one
of the guys made the pastel week another
guy was in second phase and he got
dropped for a pool comp and then the
other guy he was he got up right around
the third week Mark or four week Mark in
first phase he got injured and he got
rolled out
guy got dropped for pool comp in second
phase up and then what did you say the
other one was the one guy made it past
hell week and something happened when he
was waiting a class up for second phase
and they dropped him and then the third
guy he made it I think to like week
three or four
and then got hurt or quit he got I think
he well he said he got right right yeah
yeah so you know no one ever quits yeah
yeah no one ever
so you had a pretty good idea of what
you're going into yeah because like I
can tell you I didn't have anybody that
I didn't know anyone that went to Seal
training at all you know because I was
in the civilian world so for me I didn't
know what pool comp was I didn't
understand anything it was just a blank
open nothing and do nothing but you had
a decent idea of what was going to be
coming yep yep I good I was I was
physically and mentally prepared for
first phase did you get your pull-up
squared away
I did I actually went in a little better
with my pull-ups and you know the deal
when you show up and you start classing
up you're starting from scratch again so
now you're you from where I came in I
was coming back down uh with you know my
run times and swim times and all that
stuff I mean you're in better shape than
what was required yes yeah which is the
way you freaking should try and get
there yep yep so you show up to buds
did you get what you expected yes yeah
it was it was full benefit so it was
good times
what class were you in I was in 194. so
we start we classed up I want to say
right around January of uh 1994.
would you have the did you have problems
with anything
in buds yeah oh yeah
yeah
so first phase first phase and third
phase were
those came a lot more natural to me I
grew up hunting and fishing and shooting
guns and doing all that fun stuff so
third phase wasn't bad first phase I was
mentally prepared for second phase I'd
never scuba dived I never did any diving
and for me that was the hardest phase
you know I actually failed a couple
events in there like I failed pool comp
the the first go-round you know then
when I did my retest I passed it and
then like every little thing you know
you're doing ditch and Dawn you're doing
all these little things with scuba tanks
and going down and doing stuff like I
was jacking it all up and for me my
learning style I really have to
Digest
you know what it is I need to do and
kind of like visualize it and things
were on a quick tempo for guy face so it
wasn't uh yeah it wasn't good for me did
you feel like you're on the bubble the
whole time like when I feel pool comp I
was like all right damn I'm not gonna
make it through this man you know you're
on the wall of shame that doesn't help
either you're like looking at bricks
you're like geez you know I failed pool
comp too yeah
I had our Ops guy from trade net our Ops
worn officer from trade at put me
through yeah pool comp
Savage yeah he just well you know what's
crazy with pool comp like I'm going
through and in my head I had the
procedures down
and I thought I did good I'm like I'm
down there tying the whammy not doing
all this [__] and I'm like I'm cool calm
collect I'm going through the procedures
and the instructor just Yanks me up by
the tank she's like you failed get on
the wall and I was like damn seriously
like I'm going through trying to think
of what I did wrong I'm like I I thought
I was good you know but I didn't know if
they were playing games with me or what
but I went over on the wall I was like
[__] I don't know if I'm gonna make it
that uh that guy that failed me who's a
great guy but when he he same thing he
had me down there I was down there pool
comp was 30 minutes when I went through
and I know they shortened it at some
point to 20 minutes but when I went
through it was 30 minutes and he just
what he did was was he just uh he ripped
my mask off and then he just started
doing like a bob and he would Bob down
he would come down he would just knock
the regulator out of my mouth and then
he'd go back up and I would grab the
regulator I put it back in I'd clear it
and then he'd knock it out again and he
did that for 19 minutes damn
and then and I just kept replacing it
and every one of those breaths was a
nightmare because you're trying to
get them get the water out of there
swallow some of the water and then get a
breath and then boom he'd knock it out
again and you can't defend yourself you
can't protect yourself and you can't
Panic so I just kept doing it and then
at 19 minutes he just comes down and
gives me the Thumbs Up come to the
surface
and I come up and I'm like I feel fine
and he goes he goes you didn't look
comfortable down there you fail and I
was like okay so I guess that's that
Roger that yeah what's a whammy nut like
they just tighten this complex knot oh
it's like a multiple knots okay so it's
not like a specific like methodology or
is it just like a generally speaking Jam
so that during this Evolution called
pool competency also known as pool Camp
they want to make sure that you are
Beyond fully comfortable in the water
yeah you will not pass this if you're
not comfortable in the water zero
percent chance so what they do is they
they
cause problems so you have these old
school
scuba gear on like Jacques Cousteau
style stuff these big hoses one hose
goes in and one hose comes out and
they're just like rubber hoses and they
start taking these things
and they first they start off they knock
off your mask they rip off your fins
they pull your regulator out and then
they start pulling your regulator out
and then like undoing your thing and
eventually they pull it out and put it
behind you pull your regulator behind
you and tie it in a knot you gotta take
your gear off pull the rig over your
back untie the knot start breathing
again put everything back on in order
following the procedures as soon as you
get it back on Boom they hit you again
and so they keep doing this and
eventually they give you what's called a
whammy knot which is a knot that you
cannot get out it won't come out so now
what you have to do is Ditch your rig
which means you have to take it off you
have to lay it on the bottom of the pool
you have to take your weight belt off
and place it on top of the tank so they
don't float then you have to kiss your
regular or kiss your manifold yeah you'd
kiss your manifold oh no you request
permission to go up they give you
permission you know you get you give
them a thumbs up they give you like an
okay thumbs up then you kiss your
manifold and then you blow and go to the
surface and kiss your manifold you
literally the the part of the scuba tank
is called a manifold it's where the
regulator kind of comes out of you kiss
that like why I don't get it because
those are the procedures
okay like you gotta follow these
directions
right did you have to kiss your manifest
yeah so you kiss your manifold and then
you blow and go which means you're not
gonna give yourself a an air ambulism by
the by the air expanding your lungs and
you go to the surface you blow and go to
the surface when you get to the surface
you give a thumbs up and you say I feel
fine yeah and they either say you know
good job you passed or they say you
looked uncomfortable you failed which
for me they said you looked
uncomfortable if you failed and then for
Steve they said you looked uncomfortably
failed uh I would say though one thing
that's different about me
was I did good on everything else so
when I failed pool comp I was like oh
God like this is it I can't I'm I'm
gonna fail I was super sketched out
yeah not me that wasn't my first time
failing so so you like failed like
ditching down body breathe
I was good on the Buddy breathe uh ditch
and Dawn and something else I don't know
what else I felt but it was like three
things it wasn't good my buddy breathe
partner was a freaking wrestler from
Iowa he was a beast of a guy he was a
total freaking panic in the water this
dude would take the freaking buddy
breathe from me because you're using one
set of scuba tanks he would take it and
just breathe off of it for like a long
time yeah and then he then I'd be like
hey you know like give him a single like
hey bro I need that right now you know
and so he'd give it back to me and as
soon as I took one breath he'd be like
you know giving me the signal he needs
more mm-hmm
ah but you but you passed a second time
yep passed it made it out made it made
it into third phase and then third phase
was uh uneventful easy you know you're
just doing a lot of running swimming and
shooting so it was it was that was a lot
easier than second phase
for me
and running you were good running good I
had all my run times down before I went
into bud so I wasn't so concerned about
run I was just worried about kind of
getting injured swimming what about the
open ocean swims good to go
no Factor no Factor did you you you were
honor man yeah yeah so I so and you were
firing the gut yeah so the weight is
impressive dude yeah the way they worked
it is I think we voted the fire in the
gut before the honor man results came
out you know the class voted that for me
and I was like all right that's awesome
and then they're like hey Ward you got
honor man too and I was like all right
check Roger that
um what what well the reason I say
that's impressive is
the honor man is usually somebody that's
like it does really well in all the
events like running swimming of course
and the fire in the gut is usually a guy
that like doesn't there's a guy that had
to kind of gruel through it and gut
through it to pass like in my class it
was Jeff Higgs who had hypothermia
multiple times like five or six times
and he just he he showed back up to buds
even though they kicked him out he
showed up to class in his dungarees and
just kept doing it so he got firing up
like of course and then honor man was
Keith come here who's a total stunt
athlete but
for you to get both those that's pretty
freaking yeah so how did you even get
that I don't know I don't know man I
don't know it didn't feel like it were
you one of the leading guys were you an
E4 at this point so yeah I'd made E4 off
the ship before I went to Bud so I
showed up the buds and I was in E4
already were you the class leading petty
officer those are like a second class no
we had a second class in there and I
think eventually we had a you know he
got the the guy uh original lpo he got
stress fractures and um had real bad
shunts on it so he got rolled out and
another guy came in you know he took
over the class helpio stuff so
what was hell week like for you
I'll tell you what hell week wasn't it
wasn't as bad as I thought it was gonna
be it sucks for everyone
I had enough gas in my tank I think I
could have went one more day but it you
know it was manageable yeah it was
manageable we just had a guy on who
ended up in SF but he went to Buds and
he didn't make it through buds but he
said buds was really really hard you
know he was like he goes if you're
thinking you're gonna go there you're
going to get what you asked for yeah
yeah yeah well yeah for me how weak was
kind of cool because I wasn't the best
runner I wasn't the best swimmer and so
it was like hard for me like I had to
put out super hard to pass those
evolutions and I had the fear of failing
yeah and and hell week you there's no
time limit on there's no time limit on
the evolutions just keep going and I'm
pretty good at keeping going that's
that's a that's a good thing I'm good at
just keep going no matter what
the one thing I remember about Helwig is
remember we're doing Steel Pier that was
one of the coldest points I'd had in my
life you know they were hosing us off on
that thing and it felt like my damn hip
flexors were gonna pop off we're doing
flutter kicks and then they'd pop it in
the ocean and the ocean had been around
60 degrees but the ocean was way warmer
hot so you're in there and you're like
oh man this is great keep us in the
ocean for a little longer you know and
they'd pop you back up there back and
forth and man I could barely walk when
we got off of that damn that damn Pier
so the pure evolution in hell week was
was horrible and then the instructor's
just wrenching down on that rope when
you're carrying the boats to and from
child that [__] sucked you mean
wrenching down on the Rope so that the
thing is pulling down on your head on
your head yes yeah yeah I thought my
Little Neck was gonna snap off there
were they jumping from boat to boat when
you were we had instructors in our boat
I don't remember them jumping to another
boat but we were carrying them around
structures were jumping from boat to
boat damn and like I remember hearing my
freaking neck bones just grinding yep
and I was like this doesn't seem like
it's good for me but oh well yeah
so honor man and firing the gut guy and
of course you check into team five and
no one cares about any of that no one
cares they're like hey new guy grab go
clean the [__]
thought I got away from these [__] or
something they're following me
everywhere I just checked into team five
yep checked into team five in August
1994 and then back then you know we
started to go through sdt so they pop
you into platoon and you start doing
your platoon workout but you also gotta
detach from your platoon and go over and
go through uh seal tactical training oh
no kidding so yeah okay so but your your
platoon work up started our platoon work
up we it was almost we were a couple
months before starting the workout but
we were broken off and and going to stt
and the platoon had just started some
things when we had finished up
and you went to the group stt didn't you
no team I think you know it was just a
team just to your team okay just our
team yep I thought they had already
combined because eventually they
combined yep where every guy went
directly to a group well not directly
but everyone went through stt together
for a while or they still do now but
there was a time when they started I
thought they started around that time so
with you it's just guys from Team five
yep yep
was it run by team five it was run by
team five are training yeah that's the
same thing that I did and well did you
have any idea what your job was going to
be no I got you know put in a Batoon and
uh initially I was a a dub a dub guy in
there and I worked in there the problem
I had with AWS I was left-handed oh and
uh we'd had one of our guys in training
and he's like hey man you're the dude's
left-handed why do you guys have him
shooting an a dub because you know how
all the rounds or the brass and
um the link yeah link or going out to
the right which is going right across
your Field of Fire and then you're in
your face and stuff so like hey put them
on rear security so
got on a rear security for that first
platoon and then worked in there and
dabbled around in first lieutenant and
uh ordinance
what kind of platoon was it just a spec
ops spec ops platoon yup yup so we were
deploying out to a little island out
there on the Pacific did you uh how was
how was like your platoon leadership
the first platoon was not was not good
so I got to see hey what wrong looks
like you know
and it was kind of funny like our uh it
was a classic case of you know our OIC
was was a good dude but I think he was
too smart for his own good and uh he I
think he was a little more concerned
with
PT and being in good shape and he was a
phenomenal athlete like in one of them
triathlete guys but it came at the cost
of showing up to dive evolutions on time
she came at the cost of being a good
tactical leader down on the ground which
is what everyone's hungry for
um so I think he kind of lost you know a
lot of our guys respects and he was kind
of hard-headed you know that that
classic uh I'm smarter than everyone
else type thing so it didn't go over
good and it was just a
it was weird you know it was weird and I
didn't realize how you know
trying to find a good way to word this
it wasn't an ideal platoon right you
don't realize that until you get into a
really good position for you you didn't
know anything different so for you
that's just the way a platoon was yep
yep and the scary thing about that is
you get such a big impression made on
you by your first platoon yeah that if
you're not careful
you can think that other platoons are
jacked up because they're not like your
first platoon yeah you know you're so
impressionable yeah
yeah so it was it was interesting so the
there was a huge difference between my
first platoon and third between our my
the third platoon I did we were like the
best platoon at the team and it felt
good like the leadership was dialed in
they were balanced out our platoon Chief
was squared away well respected he was
good tactically he was good
administratively like that's the dude I
want to be like you know that wasn't
your third platoon that was my third
platoon you know my second platoon was
was better than my first still a lot of
room for improvement you know and were
you rear security did you move a
deployment or something yeah yeah moved
up to uh Point man at some point I think
my second Batoon and third Batoon I was
running point run and point you're tall
for appointment I know how tall are you
yeah
um six two yeah because you have a dub
written all over you till they find out
you're left-handed
and what were you you know just to give
people a reminder this is the 90s so we
don't have a lot of assets nope we don't
have a lot of money nope we don't have
we're not really doing any real missions
barely no uh you know some guys like
Gardner win to Somalia uh but that was a
real rare occurrence yeah
so what we would do is train get ready
you go on deployment kind of party
um
it's kind of like what the what the
scene was yeah I was it was kind of
funny because when I showed up to the
team Gardner was already in there he
already had a couple platoons on his
boat I'm on the damn quarter deck watch
and uh this dude has a long name he
still then so I don't say his name but
he had a long name and I'm like
attention to the team five compound
so-and-so you know reports of the
quarterback and I butchered his name
what do you think is calling me on the
damn phone you know Gardner he was a
hard case man hey you at the new guy say
his name right [__] man yeah pretty good
Gardener invitation yeah it was and I
was like damn I'm not getting out of the
compound tonight without getting taped
up and throwing in a damn Mill van you
know yeah so but so this was 94 yeah
because at that time
actually yeah at those years you were
starting to get a migration to team five
from like for instance from Team One if
people wanted to leave team one if they
didn't like the Stalag yeah and so
there's a whole like gang of guys that
went down to team five I remember that
to just get yeah to have some Freedom no
fun one yeah no migrate down the street
they were coming on down the street
great North garner Gardner was always at
Team five so he would but he was just
like why would I want them more like why
would I want to be over there where
there's a bunch of rules that you have
to follow
yeah oh God it was funny man you could
always find Gardner out when we were
doing uh working in the desert because
you just look for some smoke a look for
fire look for fire there's Gardner he's
like some [__] on fire Gardener guy
so uh you do your third platoon and then
what what are you thinking what do you
think about your life at that point so
what year is it so this is uh I finished
my third platoon in 99 and uh so I was
going through a divorce had a kid and I
was like hey I gotta hit the reset
button so I I talked to our Mass Chief
our CMC I was like hey man he's like hey
we want to bring you in here and be the
training sell lpo and I was like hey man
I I got a lot of baggage right now I
need to
break contact here go reset so I got
orders over to our special boat team at
the headquarters element and I got put
in their training cell and we were
basically setting up operational
Readiness exercises just like we used to
run yep so so you went just so everyone
understands you went from instead of
being a team training cell which you're
gonna be gone all the time doing
training trips you go to a boat training
and then the ore training so you're
gonna be home a lot more yes yep and so
at that point I was ready to go back to
school so as soon as I got there I was
already enrolled back in college on like
a a one-year
I don't know what you'd call it but you
know they have the military program so I
was going to school Saturday and Sunday
to knock out all my upper level units
from my bachelor's degree and then I was
working on my lower level units at the
same time so I did I wounded up
finishing up my degree in about three
years and so I'm there going into the
training we're home away trips every now
and then every now and again and uh it
was good man I had good leadership in
there these you know the special Warfare
combatant craft crewmen them dudes are
squared away and so I got to learn a lot
about the boats and in that playoff or
it helped me out later on because you're
really learning you know hey how far can
these things go load capacity all those
key tactical things that matter when it
comes into a mission planning process
for training or for a mission yeah and
what's good is you start to relate those
to helicopters and aircraft and vehicles
and so it gives you a better sense
because as a young team guy I was really
lucky I was a I was a communicator I was
a calm guy so I was always involved in
the planning
more than my peers right the point man
might plan the the in you know the route
but like I was like okay here's what
we're gonna here's what we're gonna do
for communications during the insert and
then once we're on target so I was more
involved in planning which was super
lucky and then I did args where I was
working with the Marine Corps and
working with the big Navy so once again
what's the distance that this helicopter
can take us to concert us what's the
distance that we can get with our boats
what's the distance that our ribs once
again the boats how far can they take us
what's their capacity so I was very
lucky that I got that opportunity
because once you realize how to plan
with assets it's a big it transfers to
all different assets it makes you makes
you smarter across the board yep
yep so all that was good so in uh while
I was there at the boat at the boat that
I was like hey not much going on in the
90s I was kind of like ready to punch
out of the military and so I started uh
putting in my application for the CHP
California Highway Patrol went in
through all the interview process all
the testing got my letter of acceptance
and I was kind of just on standby I was
going to transition out and then in
August of that year in 2001 I made Chief
I don't know how the LMA chief that you
know I wasn't expecting to put it on it
was like a total shocker you know and
then in September 2001 911 happened I
was like all right [__] I'm staying in
man we've been waiting a long time to
get it I've been training for whatever
if we had been seven years and years yep
yep so you know from there I worked with
uh the CMC over team five to get back
there and he's like hey I got a platoon
Chief slot open if you want him I was
like hell yeah you rolled right into a
platoon Chief slot yep
after September 11th yes so I went back
to the team I left like a few months
early Tad to go back to team five until
my orders could catch up and then got
over there and like I think right around
January February time frame we started
forming up our platoon getting ready for
a 12 month workout so you called the CMC
at Team five yep and said hey bro
yeah I would I wouldn't say I was saying
hey bro the other Mass Chief I had with
me at the boat debt he was my second
platoon Chief and he's like hey I'm
working with with Jimmy over here team
five you want to they got it spot open
you won I was like hell yeah I want it
dude my point is like
hey man build some good relationships
with people oh yeah yeah build some good
relationships with people because that
pays off you know and that means you how
do you build good relationships not by
kissing ass by working hard by doing a
good job that's how you build good
relationships when I checked into team
seven after September 11th it's actually
like whatever two years after September
11th my the the CEO there
which first of all the detailer who I
was friends with sent me to the next
deploying team so when I left I had to
go to college for receiving animal
program when I left College I went to
the next deploying team yeah that's not
luck bro and then when I got to the team
the commanding officer who I'd also
worked for in the past yeah
fired a platoon commander and put me in
as a platoon Commander
whatever three months before deployment
damn that's that's just you know that's
based on my past performance and
relationships for sure but the
relationships are built on the fact that
I worked hard and was trustworthy to get
the job done yep so you never plus you
just never know who you're going to be
working with no you know don't burn any
Bridges man don't don't burn any bridges
yeah and just going back to what you're
saying there that
your credibility in the teams is
everything your reputation yeah you
don't want to have a reputation of being
a you know a jackass
cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs you don't want to
be that yeah and your reputation
is is a
I don't know what the word to describe
it it is a heavy thing
that sticks with you it's I should say
it's a sticky thing it's a sticky thing
and if you have good reputation
it'll stick with you if you have a bad
reputation it'll stick with you it can
take people years to overturn a bad
reputation and interestingly it can also
take people years to ruin a good
reputation yeah like a person with a
good reputation can make mistakes and
people like oh yeah don't worry about it
it's Fred you know Fred's good to go
yeah or a person with a bad reputation
can make one little slip up and people
are like you gotta be kidding me we need
to get rid of this guy Paul is trying to
get him out of here yeah yeah I like and
I hate to say that because right that's
like that's like what that's like
political and all this stuff
yeah but it's just the reality of the
situation and there's there's a reason
for that because look human beings are
going to mess up but if you I guess the
difference is you have a good a good
person with a good reputation they earn
that reputation by consistent good
performance yeah
and eventually that reputation stands on
its own and therefore if they make a
mistake
which everyone's going to make mistakes
when they make a mistake when they make
a mistake which they will
people go oh you know like guess what
you know what they've done they've done
a hundred good things that's how they
built that reputation now here comes a
bad one all right we'll we'll carry on
whereas if you've done a bunch of bad
things
and now you do something bad you're
you're good you don't have any leg to
stand on yeah yep you're screwed so that
reputation thing and it's every it's
everywhere
it's everywhere but man in the teams
it's a it's a big thing yeah it's a big
thing it's damn near everything it's
damn near everything it's damn near
everything you're rep uh so you roll in
now you're a platoon a platoon Chief at
Team five yep getting ready to deploy
yes yep at what point do you realize you
guys are going to Iraq we didn't know
until probably January 2003.
so we're you know I'm there I get there
in October 2001 January February 2002 we
start our 12 month long workup cycle and
it's going through and it looks like Hey
we're going into Iraq you know
um we no one really understood the scale
of that thing how big it would wind up
being how many years it would wind up
being you know so when they told us hey
you're going over we're like hell yeah
man this is awesome you know because you
like everybody else in the teams was
worried that there would be a
three-month war and you'd miss the whole
thing exactly exactly which is so hard
to explain to people especially now that
we've been at War for almost 20 years
straight yeah it's hard to explain to
people how much it meant to go to war
when there was no war going on yeah it
was everything like you were just like
man this is going to be awesome you know
and everyone's getting prepped you know
you're like I don't know what to expect
everyone was thinking they had chemical
weapons you know you know we were going
through all kinds of mob drills with our
CBR gear and just going through
everything or you guys we're getting
everyone tuned up so we were dialed in
and you're looking at the freaking mop
uniforms oh yeah and it's like got a
elastic drawstring at the waist and like
you're thinking wait a second this is
supposed to keep me alive ain't
happening whatever let's rock and roll
did you ever think that you ever take
that charcoal freaking light Laden suit
and be like hey how wait you're saying
this thing's Gonna Save Me It's got some
elastic drawstring around the ankles and
that's supposed to keep me good to go
yeah that mop suit didn't have a good
reputation dude for sure it was it was
lacking
I don't know what the U.S government
paid for those mop suits
and what level of security they provided
us but I don't have a lot of confidence
I guarantee it was a lot and the gas
masks dude like one of the chances yep
but that's what we were getting told we
were going to do and not one single guy
said no because we I did one op where we
mopped up because we thought we were
hitting a Target that had allegedly
some whatever chemical weapons and you
know what everyone did everyone got
jocked up everyone put those gas masks
on everyone put those stupid freaking
Uniforms on I'll tell you what we had
quite a few missions when we got over to
Iraq where we were going around with
some of those three letter agencies
looking all over the place seeing what
was around and everything we saw was uh
was old it was like it'd been there left
you know nothing new at all you know
um as far as CBR CBR yeah [__] like all
the facilities and everything was like
nothing's been here for a long ass time
so
so all right well let's so you get done
with your work up you find out you're
going to Iraq in January and you guys
are going on deployment in like April or
something yep yep April time frame so uh
Team three was already over there and
just going back to your relationships
piece we had a couple guys on the
platoon's that were dialed in with some
team three guys and they started sharing
information you know back and forth hey
here's what's going on here's what to
expect so that gave us a really good
idea on what we needed to to prep for
and so right around April time frame we
deploy over to Kuwait and we're staging
in Kuwait waiting to go into Iraq team
threes I think wrapping things up at
that point and we might have already
turned over with them
um and we're actually in
um Kuwait for a a handful of weeks there
I want to say right around three weeks
and we actually did our first off out of
Kuwait into Iraq on 53s yeah that was
that sounded like a crazy op it was good
it was a good ShakeOut nothing nothing
happened but we planned for 96 hours we
went through all of our helicopter
rehearsals you know and it was a big up
we loaded up those uh our dpvs doesn't
Patrol vehicles and we went in with a
big package and we what was your mission
to go take down the dam get control get
control it wasn't Hadith it was
somewhere up North Korea okay look
around so uh we went up there and it was
a long ass flight in there and we're all
jacked up on the catnip you think you're
going to get in the [__] you know and
we're flying there we got our enr plan
laid out in case a helicopter gets shot
down we got our mop Gear with us yeah
and we're roping down all 53s onto the
dam with our CBR gear you look like you
know Mitchell and snowman were you
masked up when you when you fast roped
we or not the game plan was Secure the
dam get everything set up get everything
cleared and then they had some tunneling
systems in there because it was a dam
they wanted us to go inside the
tunneling system see if there's any you
know weapons of mass destruction or
chemical weapons in there so
the once we secured the dam which it
took a little while because you don't
really think about how big a dam is on
the inside there's a lot of [__] going
on in there
um is this a one platoon op this is so
we have like a cartoon plus no we had
platoon plus we had our platoon our
Mobility element and we also brought in
some STV Bubbas which was good they'd
already been there and they cleared a
ton of ships small you know little uh
what do you call the little boats out
there dowels dowels they cleared a ton
of dials so these guys had already had
some reps under the belt so we were
excited to uh to get them on the off of
those but yeah we went in there on
eventful cleared it chucked the tunnels
nothing there then we you know waited
there a couple days and we uh pulled out
but that that's a that's like a big
that's the big mesh that we were
planning for in the 90s like that type
of thing yeah like hey here it is yeah
you're gonna Hilo in this is the big
mesh and plus that was your first combat
operation yes yep it was a big deal like
you felt good to get that under our belt
in the mid and we we
um it was a good ShakeOut for planning
because you know you're over there going
through the 96 hour planning cycle
um a lot of good Lessons Learned first
time using 53s on a mission like that
um so it was good you know and one of
the things I jacked up was me and
another guy or medical guy who scored
away dude he stayed in the teams for a
while
but we roped down and we had our CBR
gear strapped on our sides and so as
we're coming down we got that damn Molly
pack you know you got to weave it in and
out of the the nylon I didn't weave mine
in and out like I was supposed to so I
went through a couple but I left like
the bottom undone and I don't know if I
hit the wheel or the skin of the
aircraft but that thing that damn thing
came popping off of course I had my mvgs
in there oh the Hilo you know and the uh
the backpack goes over the side same
thing with the other cat that was with
me we think the world of washed you know
put it in the river and stuff and
everyone always talked about hey it's
not a big deal you can you get you know
write it off as a combat as a combat
loss that's what everyone was talking
about you know like all right yeah I
guess it's not the big of a deal combat
last I was like dude the skipper was not
happy the combat loss write-off was
not a thing
well what's really not a thing is trying
to do a night clearance without nods
without night vision we white lighted
everything then okay so back then we're
coming up on the day and we're white
lightning and then even the clearance on
the inside so you're lucky
in that respect
what do you mean I'm saying if you see
you said you lost your nods right oh
yeah yeah I'm saying you're lucky that
you didn't yes didn't need them yeah
yeah
yes that is accurate because that would
have freaking you'd have just been blind
walking around yep waiting to yeah walk
into a wall yeah it was it was just
buddy along with somebody yeah it was a
good lesson learned from me especially
to in Chief
did you uh that little Molly weave how
many Molly weaves did you make like two
I think I had about three in there I
think there was around five and I just
left out the last two and snapped it and
snapped her in yep snapped her in get
her done she's good not so good
not a good situation and the skipper was
pissed oh he was hot man I was on the
mat with him like he's you know call me
the task on that one yeah luckily like I
said you had a good reputation like if
you had a bad reputation at that point
that would have really sucked yeah yeah
would have really sucked yep so that was
your first big mesh and then what but
that was out of Kuwait that was out of
Kuwait yep then what happened then we
moved up into Baghdad we had a little
camp set up out there at uh we called
the camposa you know we had a I don't
know if you know Posey but Warren
officer Vietnam dude yeah yeah good like
yeah good stories and we had another guy
we called him Ranger and uh those two
dudes came in they helped build out the
camp you know we took a Ranger with us
on uh on quite a few missions good dude
and then we just started operating out
of Posey into Baghdad yeah we were right
there at the Baghdad International
Airport and what I was impressed with
looking back what I am impressed at
looking back is
you guys were freaking super proactive
in getting missions started like you
guys were super proactive in forming
relationships and and getting the Intel
that you needed from various sources and
and starting to do a lot of operations
yeah we set the foundation for you guys
if you guys came in and did like four
times more than what we did but we were
definitely laying that foundation and
one of the things we had our attached
unit senior enlisted leader
um he was dialed in and he came from
damn neck and so he had a lot of good
relationships and you know you know damn
Nick was over there at that point and so
he was tied in with a lot of the
three-letter agencies which opened up
the door with quite a few missions
shared intelligence so that really
helped set that up that foundation for
us and then from there we were starting
to get you know some good missions in
hell even if you're getting one Mission
you're like all right we're good to go
you know because you think we all think
we're gonna be out of there within six
seven months like the whole thing's
shutting down yep
um but obviously it didn't yeah so
what was your you guys gotten some gun
fights too yeah what was it what was the
first one like what do you remember our
first shootout was kind of funny
we were dialing in our standard
operating procedures for a shootout
um which we hadn't done like you know we
went through training training was good
but it was nowhere near the level that
you know we provided our guys once we
got over and traded it wasn't anywhere
near that
so we identified a few of the gaps we
had and we went we developed we brought
on the platoon we brought in guys with
experience and we developed our standard
operating procedure for what we're going
to do inside a house if we're getting a
shootout and it was basically suppressed
Fire cover crash maneuver using a cover
and move we're going to deploy some
crashes someone's going to be
suppressing fire while all that's
happening
so on this particular Mission we went in
and uh
the house the guy marked for us was the
wrong house we didn't know that well on
imagery everything looked dialed in
tight and they mark it it looks good we
go in preach the door so we've gone
explosive so now the neighborhood's
starting to wake up we clear the house I
kept everything on the clock we cleared
the you know two-story house in under
two minutes and we get the call on the
net hey reset the hot the actual Target
house is down the street so we reset
reconsolidate you know ones on the left
twos on the right gear check you know
sensitive equipment check everyone's
good come back out of the house grab our
wood ladders Patrol back down the road
and the right house is marked and we go
up there and it was the right house it
had a double security screen door would
go explosive on it we got a a failed
breach so now it's turning into a big
construction project guys are up and not
to mention it just so everybody knows
like after you've hit the first house
everybody in a two mile Square radius
knows what's happening and if you're in
that neighborhood you know exactly
what's happening so if you're a bad guy
in that neighborhood
you are now alert and ready to be
attacked and you're prepping yep exactly
so now we got a fail breach we're on the
outside of the structure the preachers
are working through getting through that
heavy security screen door
um we're kind of raking Windows we're
deploying crashes in there to keep
people away from the front door we
finally get entry clear the first floor
everything's good we're dialed in and
back then we always pressed into our
guys hey you make the call if you stack
on the stairs you're the number two guy
you got three or four more guys behind
you make the call and go up the stairs
we don't want to just have this lag
period where you're waiting for me or
the OIC to make a decision to tell you
what to do decentralized command so the
guy stack on the stairs I'm right there
I just came out of the the kitchen area
they start moving up the stairs and
there's a young kid upstairs with an
AK-47 so he's like 10 feet away and he's
just full auto
and our guys are on the stairs they're
trying to return fire but the volley's
just all around our dudes man
um I'm yelling at the guys get back down
here they come back down the stairs and
then we go through our shootout
procedures which which pay dividends
they work we couldn't shoot get at the
guy because the guy's on the second deck
and now we're down below so there's no
way to get the direct fire so our guys
are exposing themselves a little bit
trying to get an angle here guys are
deploying crashes we deployed about five
six crashes there's no more gunfire
we're like all right check
um we're going up so you know we go up
the stairs the kid had actually dropped
is going we clear this uh the second
deck there's freaking smoke everywhere
so it's just I mean we're gagging
there's so much smoke in the house
um go up there the guy's not there we're
like where the hell would this guy go
and um our guys go out on the on the on
the deck patio and they're clearing and
now we're looking really hard like where
is this guy and the kid is a young kid
hiding behind curtains and you know the
guy's there and then boom our guys
muzzle strike the guy get him into the
center room we cuff him up and that was
that so anyone get hit by him by the bad
guy you know our our guy heading up the
stairs first the first guy up he had a
graze over his mvgs
um it actually hit his his Mount
um but he didn't get hit it was like it
was a total Pulp Fiction Pulp Fiction
scenario yeah like he had angels on his
because that could have been a bad night
we could have had two three guys hitting
that one ball and no one got hit we we
were extremely lucky how many how many
rounds do you think the guy shot one mag
or two mags did he get a Reload no no he
didn't get a Reload he I think he got a
full mag off somewhere in between 25 and
30 rounds damn dude yeah from 10 feet
yeah yep close it's close I mean I know
how he he probably missed because he was
on Full Auto you know all those things
yeah you're just bouncing all around and
going full auto
um and the dude you know the guy was
just a total douchebag that shot at us
too amazed like I love George Bush I
love Coca-Cola and you're like you're
just shut up man
so yeah we cuffed him up and that was
that was emotional when you're getting
shot at that close and you're dealing
with a bad dude that just tried to kill
you
you know those uh emotions get jacked up
pretty high
um we had some good teammates here I
mean I was I wanted to kill the dude
um but we can't do that you know as much
as you want to yes you're gonna it's not
gonna be good
but we got him cuffed up took them over
to our Detention Facility and you know
the guys did good that night and they
did good because of the training the
talk throughs that we did going through
the checklist going through multiple
rehearsals every time these missions
came up all that
panned out all that worked in our favor
for that one event for that one shootout
that all worked for us you know having
uh having contingency plans which is
that what you guys had and it's what you
know we have all kinds of contingency
plans I mean every IAD every immediate
action drill that we do is a contingency
plan like oh if we get shot at from over
there so we're gonna shout out from over
there that's what we're gonna do so
having those contingency plans
it just makes it so that you don't
really have to think decentralized
command just works everyone knows what
to do they know what the objective is
they make it happen and so you can make
very little call very very you can give
very little Direction and things still
will proceed the way they're supposed to
yeah
what about um
what about your next what about your
next gun fight so our next one I think
was our uh our helicopter so we've gone
in after this guy and he um
he shot an RPG and killed an army guy
and so we were going in after him and so
we came and we did quite a bit of healer
work that deployment so we came in with
our helicopters and our game plan was to
you know land on the X assault the
building and get grab the guy and go and
he was out in this uh I think he was
actually out in Fallujah romantic so
there were some Palm grows out there
so on insertion we come in in the
helicopters went to the wrong house you
know an rmbgs back then they're kind of
they're not good so we could see all
that so we we sat down and we're like
this is not the right house get back up
they get back up do one orbit come back
in to the right house land us we dump
off clear the building everything's on a
vehicle we get the bad guy now as we're
going through all the uh sensitive side
exploitation we're trying to grab as
much as we can on this guy
you know we get a report as we're
breaking out that hey there's two or
three armed guys coming your way into
this Palm Grove
so the helicopters were a ways out but
we had a gunship overhead
and so we set up a quick HD perimeter
little foot Shook and we're going to
wait to see if these guys came into us
well they never came into us they sent
something was wrong and they bagged out
so we get set up in the Palm room when
we're calling in the helicopters at this
point to come pick us up and as we're
setting up the perimeter you know
someone calls out over the radio hey man
there's a tracer fire that just went by
and no one else had seen it there's one
dude paying attention in his Field of
Fire sees one round come in and so he
calls it out so we kind of go on hyper
alert here we're waiting we're watching
and as the heroes are coming in this
dude they were probably like 300 yards
from us they start opening up with AAA
fire over our LZ now the only thing
protecting us at that time is we had a
Palm Grove nails here and the house is
somewhere over here so this Tracer fire
is coming over the Palm Grove
and the the issue we had is like um
communicating this back up the chain we
had our attaching commander on the
ground with us on this one
and some people just didn't see this
[__] some people didn't see the Tracer
Fire coming and I picked it up pretty
damn quick once the guy called it out
you're like holy [__] that's a good
volley of fire we're gonna get a
helicopter shot down if we're not care
for her so anyways the helicopter comes
in picks up the package grabs our
headquarters on it they bounce out and
then we just go over to our secondary LZ
which was you know pretty easy but uh it
was very uncomfortable knowing that you
got Triple A Fire coming over the top of
you you know one of these helots get
shut down it's going to be a long night
especially out here in this rural area
we didn't have any backup
and then what was your op Tempo like
it wasn't bad it wasn't like we were
going out digging targets every night
but we would uh we got a point there
where we were going out at least twice a
week I'd say once or twice a week yeah
more like twice a week but in between
that we were doing other stuff like
you're doing mobility stuff you're going
to do a little bit of sniper stuff here
and there
um which which was which was good and
then just going back on decentralized
command you know the the other CQC or
close quarter combat shootout we had you
know our guys were going up
to this uh house
and man there's freaking telephone wires
everywhere man and you know how that is
you're like there's no Rhyme or Reason
Why do you guys live with this just
wires everywhere you know and we got to
hop over this damn gate yeah you know to
get to this house so we literally like
30 or 40 wires yeah like you could be
just total Mayhem wires yep and we we
planned for we actually picked it up on
the energy we're going through our
rehearsals and we're like hey there's
wires everywhere as you're coming over
at this spot right here be careful don't
get your nods hit on them don't you know
we got to be quiet so we start going up
and over we get the entry team over and
actually we had our our full Squad into
the courtyard because the distance from
the gate to the actual house was a lot
it was a big house so we needed
assaulters up front
so we get up front in the uh you know
the the entry teams going through you
know our preachers going through laying
the charge on the door going through all
the procedures and the next scenario you
get this whack bang bang bang doors
rounds are coming through the door and
so you know our breacher we borrowed him
from another platoon he was dialed in
good dude
um you know life gnome but so he's he's
laying the charge and he's using his
cover right if he's in the center of the
door the dude's getting shot no with the
45 Cal pistol but he's off to the side
using his covers like he's supposed to
sets the charge our guys our other guys
holding security they go through our
standard operating procedures they're
awake in the windows they're shooting in
through the window to get the person
away from it and they're dumping crashes
in to keep the person away kick them out
away from the doorway
so boom We blow it of course there's a
propane tank there so the whole damn
doorway catches on fire so now we can't
you know we got a fail breach air we
can't get in there the door's open but
there's just this massive propane fire
going on so we got to go to our
secondary door you get over the
secondary door and these these dudes got
a damn drop bar on there so we you know
I mean it took us forever to get in it
was a [__] show we get entry into the
into the doorway and there's like a
family of eight people sleeping in there
and they're like they're still sleeping
like how is it possible we just blew in
your door there's gunshots going on and
you are you all are still like
physically seeping like zombies you know
so anyways we got in there clear the
building that sounds so unbelievable if
you haven't been to Iraq before like you
can't explain things like that yeah you
can't you can't explain things like that
no to get an explosive breach a failed
breach shotguns going off of fire and
the team this freaking family just
racked out yep they're rocked out yeah
they were zombies man what did you ever
catch the guy that was shooting through
the door yeah it was uh it was actually
the
I think it was one of the guys wives
shooting through there and she was like
Hey I thought you thought you were
looters you're like coming in to Rob our
house we're like yeah no we're not
polluters you know but um anyways we got
that situation all squared away
oh that's a rough that well when I say
that's a rough one that's the kind of
mission where things can go really
sideways like if you start fragging that
room oh man which you could easily do
yeah to say ham look we just got shot at
I'm throwing some frag grenades into
this room and actually you know you got
a family eight person family and they're
getting blown apart by frag grenades
because the woman was trying to defend
her house from looters which again may
sound like a crazy story and it could
also be the absolute 100 truth I don't
know I'm not gonna try and you know
replay the situation that you lived
through but yeah that could be legit
yeah and you have no idea when you're
out there and that have been that would
have been horrible yeah it would have
been a freaking nightmare yeah yeah well
any other big missions that uh that you
guys did didn't you guys do like some
some like sa7 recovery or something yeah
yeah yeah so we I forgot about that one
so we're out we went out there you know
working with some other Intel people out
there and they're like hey we're going
after some of this sensitive stuff here
we you know anyways so we went and hit
this Farmhouse we got good air coverage
over ahead of us no one's there the
place is a ghost town we start going
through our sensitive side exploitation
and man it was like a gold mine you know
the the perimeter around it was just
this big huge cash
and so we found a truckload of you know
uh sa-7 and sa-14 missiles a ton of RPGs
uh Rock of repel grenades and launchers
and so things started getting a little
spicy around there so we're calling a
little bit of a fire support and we
actually had to turn that over to an
army unit who came in the next day
during daylight and they started going
through the field and it was like right
I mean it was like radios it was like
enough [__] to outfit a damn Army you
know um so yeah that was a that was a
good off nothing happened but we found a
lot of stuff so you know you leave there
feeling pretty good about it
and that so that's a good that was a
freaking great deployment for you guys
especially in like whatever 2003 that
that deployment was pretty freaking epic
oh man we left there and we're like
we're the man we're never coming back
here again yeah because no one no one
ever thought you'd be back there again
no no no it was good and so the one
thing we did that was really good with
our platoon that we learned from the
team three guys when we relieved them is
we shared information you know I was
back with you know you know your brother
there team one communicating everything
I had back to him hey here's what we're
doing here's what worked here was here's
what didn't work here's some things to
think about with mobility and you just
try to share as much information as
possible you know that way the next
guy's coming in they know what to expect
and they can adjust training come in at
a high level ready to rock and roll I
know when you guys came in you guys did
I don't know four times four or five
times the amount of missions we did for
that deployment yeah well you get you
guys were pushing a lot of information
back to us I know you guys were feeding
my platoon Chief and my platoon Chief
was already like a Mobility kind of
Mobility dude and so he was just amped
bro we were doing freaking uh [__]
tire change drills like NASCAR like a
pit crew I mean it was just like it was
on but here's the funny thing we were we
were on an ore
prior to that deployment so like maybe
three months before going on deployment
we were on an or we we did our ore
shipboard and we went and we were doing
hydrographic reconnaissance of red Beach
up at Camp Pendleton with LED light and
slate dude like it was the world hadn't
caught up yep right the world hadn't
caught up yet and thank God you know
like after that we were we we found some
Humvees we borrowed Humvees from like
the Seabees or something and started
running up running you know training Ops
down it like the old
NTC the old Naval Training Center where
they had a bunch of old buildings that
were all dilapidated but we started
running little Ops in there with our you
know and our task unit Commander had
actually been in Iraq on the push-up so
he had some experience our task into SCA
had also been in Iraq on the push-up so
he had some experience
um which was awesome and they're both
great guys
so we were we and we were just going off
of the reports of how you guys were
doing stuff and we're just like okay
this is what they're doing cool this is
what we're gonna do this is what they
did this is how they rigged their
vehicles okay this is how we're gonna
rig our vehicles so that's kind of what
we did and then I know you and I did a
turnover was it we we did it like
Bahrain right yeah Bahrain that's where
I was at we had a platoon left up there
in our Mobility element was left up
there yeah we came back a few weeks
early out of ball ranges because there
was enough room to bring everyone in So
yeah so we sat down did an awesome
turnover with you guys
with you and your OIC yep who's a
freaking great dude that was awesome and
I was kind of like I knew who you were
yeah
just from I guess being around but then
that was that was when I was like that's
when I first really remember getting a
working like you know I might have seen
you have mcps or something you know but
the first time I ever actually got a
working I think that was the first time
I ever did some kind of working uh I
think it was the first time I crossed
paths with you yeah yeah always hear the
name out there I mean I was roommates
with taco and taco had nightmare stories
with you and Chris he's like those guys
man they need to quit beating us up
we were we were
hostiles yeah we had the gang mentality
for sure for sure
um so what'd you do when you got home
from that deployment so got back off
that deployment and uh there was another
platoon Chief slot open so the seems he
was like hey man you the guy that was
gonna come doesn't look like he's going
to come you want to do another one I was
like hell yeah dude so then you know
started forming up another platoon got a
bunch of new guys in new OIC and uh
started another 12 month workup cycle
dang that's do you have freaking two
platoon Chief slots yep yep it was
awesome man that's the best job in the
world the task unit spot is is good the
Two Chief saw it's a lot oh yeah the
platoon Chief I mean I always say like
E5 in a platoon I was just talking to
some guys the other night that were
e-files from student I was like hey
you're good man E5 of platoon is an
awesome place to be and it is it is it's
an awesome place
to be and hopefully you reach a point
where you go I can take care of those
awesome guys yep and that's when you go
okay I'm gonna be an opio or I'm going
to be a platoon Chief or I want to be a
you know if you go to the officer route
you can try and go that officer route
but at some point you realize
the best thing I can do as it to be a
good E5 is to take care of the other
ve5s means I got to get promoted I got
to take care of them and the best way I
can do that is to increase my rank a
little bit Yeah so I have a little bit
more sway we don't have to do dumb [__]
yep you know I'm complaining about my
boss you know you can only complain so
much before you got to actually do
something about it yeah
absolutely
and it's rare that someone gets to do
platoon Chiefs back to back like that I
mean no it's rare that a guy even gets
to do two platoon Chiefs slots that's
freaking rare yeah we're getting better
at it now that's good that's one of the
things that I know with the headquarters
level they're really looking at you know
before there are um
our rating really took control over hey
you can only do one you got to move out
another guy's got to move in and they
started looking at that because you know
we had we were losing quite a few
tactical leaders like their guys are
getting fired why are they getting fired
hey they need more seasoning yeah hey
let's grab let's keep two three guys
that are doing really good to keep that
uh
going with the word I'm looking for
annuity continuity at the team and these
are dialed in people you know you can
count on them and uh move it forward so
we've gotten better with uh with that
over the last 10 years so those guys
it's common now for your top two or
three guys to stay at the team even if
they pick up Senior Chief they're going
to stay in that platoon Chief yeah
that's awesome yep that's awesome and so
then you do another workup you must have
been freaking dialed now you're doing a
second platoon Chief work up the second
platoon Chief was way easier than the
first hell yeah the first one so I
didn't do a platoon lpo so I was sucking
on a fire hose okay you know what I'm
saying oh yeah sure yeah so you know
setting up the platoon there's just if
you had never worked in training either
nope not a team see I'll tell you man
my whole
you know that's probably you know my
first three platoons the leadership
strategy tactics we were talking about
my first three platoons I learned these
certain things right yeah and I wrote
about it in leadership strategy and
tactics
but where that was like where all these
seeds got planted yeah but I'll tell you
what you want to know where the
fertilizer and the water came from on
those seeds it was working in training
cell at Seal Team one where I was a
single
enlisted E5 and you know what trip I
went on every freaking trip there was I
taught everything I would volunteer for
every course I'd you know we would go
teach land Warfare then I'd teach diving
then I teach CQC I just do and I was the
main instructor on any of them yeah I
was just a guy that was out there like
I'll go on that trip oh I'll go on that
trip
and that's where those little seeds
started to come to fruition and the
biggest thing was when you're
instructing and you know this now that
we worked in land Warfare when you're
running when you're watching iads or
you're teaching I ads you you are de
facto detached so you're watching and
you can see and you realize how easy it
is when you're detached and when you
realize how easy it is when you're
detached and you go wait a second if I'm
in there I just need to take a step back
and see what the hell is going on and
that can make a good call
so that is where I learned so much so
for you have not done that definitely
how to make your first platoon Chief go
around a little rough it was hard I got
lucky like the our sister platoon that
platoon Chief was dialed in he'd done
all those things he was on his like
seventh platoon I was doing my fourth at
the time and so I leaned on him I'd ask
him 100 million questions on things and
he always gave me good uh good guidance
man yeah Daniel good dude you know oh
yeah yeah so then you get done with that
one yep and now you're now you're going
through it again and now you're kind of
like I'm like this is easy you're
dealing with the same issues I got all
my standard operating procedures in
place so for every block of training
we're doing plus you're a freaking
combat vet I'm a combat you're kind of
the man I'm ready to get after it yeah
so it was way easier man way easier you
know I know you're always going to have
those same Personnel issues and now you
know how to deal with them you know what
right looks like
yeah
and then what was that um then you were
going back to Iraq again yep so we wound
up back over you know you guys came in
in late or September 2003 we went back
in September 2004 and the place was just
a disaster roadside bombs all over the
place I mean you know the drill four
Fighters all over the place it was a
[__] show yeah that that was the the end
of my first deployment was when we went
and got yakubi which was solder's guy
that set the whole freaking thing into a
just a total Mayhem and we saw that we
saw the
like it was it was a radical change yeah
because
before that like in what would be
in March of 2004 it was kind of like
okay we'll go do a mission in April we
were you could look out and you'd see
smoke and fire vehicles burning and like
it was totally it was a very different
scenario yeah in that one month period
in April of 2004. and
um it just got worse from there yeah and
then when by the time you guys showed up
it was yeah it was a disaster I remember
and we were doing the PSD Mission so we
weren't doing our typical direct action
but we got in there in in my platoon we
got split up so we're in squads now
supporting other platoons because you
need X number of people to protect these
guys
um and one of the good things that the
headquarters element did is they rotated
guys out for Sniper missions so if
you're a sniper qualified you've come on
in and so we covered down within our PSD
elements and guys go out and do sniper
stuff so I was lucky I got to get out
there on Haifa Street a couple times
were you a sniper yeah yeah sniper yes I
went through and went through Snapchat
every school in 98 and that was back
when it was out at coaling and stuff and
when I got back off of that deployment
night and I want to work for uh Mark he
was running the sniper course so I did a
couple instructor you know uh courses
with him so it was good and that helped
me out for you know the 2003 deployment
2004 the 2006 opponent you know oh yeah
but I remember getting out on Haifa
Street and it was the first time we're
out and we did sniper work in 2003 but
there wasn't nothing going on everything
was under control
and I remember going out there and we're
supporting an army unit if they're doing
a clearance so we come in dump out of
the Bradley set up in the in the
buildings
we got all our sectors covered and like
there's this mooge in an apartment
building with an RPG launching RPGs at
Apaches that are in the area and like
you know the daily like you don't shoot
a rocket from a room that's not good
good practice right you're going to jack
yourself up he's just in there getting
after don't and like so the package
coming and they're just like go go go go
and they just take the dude out and
you're like holy [__] man this place is
not good totally different and then you
come out for extract the Brads are
coming in to pull us out and like
there's rounds coming in at you we
didn't deal with that 2003 2003 we had
the upper hand you know you're operating
at night time but we had the upper hand
with what we were doing
um so it's just it was different and at
that same time in 2004 you had Phantom
Fury out there and Fallujah going off
you know and you had good dudes
supporting that and that was just I
remember looking up on the uh The Jock
screen and the Marines are going through
doing a clearance at night time and
there's like grenades getting chucked
out and the Marines are just going in
and getting after it I mean they're
carrying like 25 mags in there yeah and
going building by building and like God
bless the Marine Corps man these dudes
are like
badasses and we all wanted to be there
like hey switch with us man come do the
PSD thing we want to be out there doing
what you're doing
um but so anyway so you know Phantom
Fury just died down like hey we want to
send a a sniper element up to Samara and
so like Leif got chosen to be OIC and I
was like hey they selected me to come in
there with life I was like cool put our
10-man 11-man team together went up to
tomorrow we thought we were going to get
after it you know it was go time it was
go time we were going to get some and it
was on eventful man nothing happened we
set up damn near we were out in the
streets every damn day setting up man
and it was just you know that the guys
were going after they're real cage it
was like civilians like you don't know
what your enemy looked like they'd come
in and set an IED and even though they
said it and then they'd be out of there
how many how much did you spend how much
time did you spend on Haifa Street
not much I would say I probably got out
there about six or seven times total for
that and I was only in Iraq for 90 days
during that time period and then you
rotate it out to the Pacific yep yep
over to Pi yeah Guam would be uh
and the PSD was a look it was a hard
Mission and everything but relatively
uneventful because that's what we're
supposed so uh at that time seals were
providing security for the top seven
something like that uh authorities in
Iraq and you know in charge of keeping
them safe and did an awesome job yeah
but that in doing an awesome job man
there wasn't action thankfully yeah
because the action probably would have
been a giant 2000 pound V bid that would
have killed everybody or some something
crazy like that yeah in in 2004 that was
the first time we I really started
seeing the you know uh you know the
truck bombs the car bombs they were
building and I mean they built them you
know this they they put so much
explosives in them that the damn springs
and shocks would break on them you know
they'd be trying to get on base and
they're like jacked up not good so but
that but that wrapped up another
deployment for you yep and and then
so then what then what'd you do so then
stayed at Team five I made uh Senior
Chief in 2005 picked up a team you're
making up for going to the fleet UD yeah
I mean you're making rank quick man yeah
were you making rank quick for on
average above average it seems like you
are oh yeah so I would say
probably above average up to Chief and
then you know I got passed over the
first time for a Senior Chief and then
made it the second time rightfully so
you
you don't want guys to make rank too
fast you want guys to really understand
what they're doing and why they're doing
it which takes time takes a lot of
reading takes repetitions and I think
when I put on Chief I didn't I was under
gunned you know with my my training and
my experience
um so it was good that I got passed over
my first time for Senior Chief you know
so anyway so I made Senior Chief in 2005
and then picked up a task unit and you
know from there we started working up to
relieve you guys when did you guys know
that you were going to relieve us I
would say right around March April time
frame of 2006 right when you're so I
know he got there yep right around that
same time yep yep they're like you guys
are going to come in Behind These Guys
and replace them at what point did you
guys start tracking like what was
happening
you guys started getting hot and heavy
in what May June time frame
yeah in April April time yeah like as
soon as we have out there it was getting
crazy it was right around then and like
we all of us were just kind of thinking
hey it's going to be like a Fallujah
style clearance and Fallujah went pretty
quick yep it went pretty quick you know
there was a lot of you know uh
a lot of good work being done a lot of
people getting killed U.S soldiers
getting uh injured
um
we thought it was going to be like that
we didn't know it was going to be what
it was you know we hadn't gone up
against uh that type of enemy before
yeah well we thought it was going to be
a Fallujah type thing too yeah and we
talked about this on on the unraveling
with Daryl Cooper
that
we well that's what we got told when we
got there they're like hey you guys are
gonna we're gonna do Fallujah and we're
like thank you thank you this is gonna
be because Fallujah at that point was a
real high water mark for for just
awesome crushing kinetic operations by
the Marine Corps and there was seals in
their support and they did a great job
so we were thinking okay like it's on
and it's going to be whatever it's going
to be two weeks or three weeks maybe of
fighting and we'll get cleared through
the city
but it ended up not going that way it
ended up being that there's a smart move
by the Prime Minister who was a Shia to
recognize that if if the Shia Army which
it basically was a shi Army went in
there and did this type of
crushing kinetic sweep through ramadi
which was most which was Sunni it would
have set up Sunni versus Shia Civil War
and so he said we're not doing that
you're going to find another way to do
it and the other way to do it was
a counter Insurgency was going into the
neighborhoods and trying to pervert
preserve the infrastructure and trying
to keep the civilian populace as safe as
you can as you do it and yet at the same
time do battle with these insurgents so
that's what that's what we ended up
doing
and I I always wonder what it was like
for you guys once we started taking a
lot of casualties and once we started
losing guys you guys must have been like
um
foreign
nervous about coming oh hell yeah yeah
absolutely man no no one had been
through you know that amount of uh
combat like for us at that point like
heavy combat you know we had uh our
group
Commodore he was out there with us doing
our you know uh ore what do they call
the final battle problem and he's like
hey man you guys are going to ramadi
stand by there's a lot going on there
and he was like I mean a lot going on
there
and uh and I think things really hit
home for us
um like I remember Cali coming back when
he was shot and like you look at these
things you're like okay that's
manageable like hey he's shot he's
coming in through it looks like he's
gonna be okay
and then [__] really hit the fan for us
when Mark was killed we're like holy
[__] this is we're going into something
that we like you know we hadn't been in
before
um so we had like we dialed in our
training you guys were giving us
information telling us everything you're
doing what's working what's not working
we had some hard conversations with our
operators hey man like someone's gonna
get wounded someone might get killed
like we there's some of these things we
can't control what we can do is our
rehearsals train to this make good
decisions on the battlefield to reduce
our casualty levels but we're gonna be
shot at someone's gonna get hit that's
coming and at the end of the day it's
going to be us standing here that's
going to kind of get us out of this [__]
so we gotta we gotta run a tight game we
got to be tight with what we're doing
um
and the guys understood that you know
guys understood that
um
but it's different when you get on the
ground and you got a lot of rounds
coming at you you know yeah you know
it's I I try to I'm trying to think of a
way to explain the difference that in my
mind that you got like
it seems like but prior to that point
most of the times when guys would go out
even when guys would go out and get
wounded or guys would go out and no one
had been killed in Iraq yet but even in
Afghanistan it was like it was a mission
right it was like a mission an isolated
mission where something had happened and
then once that isolated mission is over
it's like you reset the clock and now
okay we're in a different it's a
different Mission and so it's almost
like like you do get to reset the clock
yeah but in ramadi was like you were in
the same game and the clock was freaking
ticking the whole time yep and and so
you guys knew that you were just gonna
come and get in the game and it wasn't
going to be one Mission and it wasn't
going to be three missions it was going
to be mission after mission after
mission after mission after mission and
it was going to be as many days as you
were there and
um yeah I remember you guys showing up
and I remember actually briefing your
task unit and literally saying
you guys are gonna you guys are gonna
take casualties which is the which was
the it was a thing I was thinking to
myself do I say that is that a bad
attitude is that a negative attitude is
that a self-fulfilling prophecy or is
that just the [__] truth about what's
going on and I would rather have you
guys thinking okay
this is the truth and if we can avoid it
great but we have to be ready and we
need to do everything we can but we got
to be ready for it yep yep I remember
you guys were telling us man we had
we had our GO bags ready so if someone
gets injured or standard operating
procedure in place with who's going with
the guy that's injured all of our
passports IDs everything are in the bag
someone gets injured boom they're
getting on the Helo with the injured guy
they're pushing out you know at least
getting them over to Germany
um so we were definitely in the right
mindset
um you know in our first op out there
you guys helped set that up out there at
firecracker oh yeah and that was that
was a good one with the Marine Corps we
set you guys up that firecracker for
your first time
yeah you're like hey you guys are going
around Racetrack and we'll just call
this uh we'll call this operation
firecracker because there's going to be
some [__] going down up there yeah it
was it was a good first ShakeOut you
know in the Marine Corps up there you
know the colonel that was running the
record I forget his name but you're just
a good outstanding good leader just good
like good dude man
um so we set that up and it you know
there's a you know our guys are snipers
killed a few guys on that one which was
good
um you know and they come just
remembering I was at home be out in the
street and he's pulling security down
from us and the dude starts you know
gets a little bit of an RPG and like the
Marines are dumping out of it and
they're doing cover Move drills getting
back and they're taking Small Arms
firing we're in position where we can't
that you know the enemy's in Dead Space
we can't even do anything to support
them
um they come back and there's a couple
like smaller Motors that came in that
day you know didn't hit our building but
they were out in front of us there it
wasn't too bad they were small
um but it was a good it was a good
ShakeOut for us like hey a little
confidence Builder whacked a couple bad
guys no one got injured these are all
good things
and then you guys start started rolling
then we started rolling in uh our first
I was on that mission the next mission
we did I was not on
and our guys went up down the street I
think from Falcon and uh they're setting
up OverWatch positions and you know
they're I think they're in the morning
time and grenades come in you know I
think they had one or two grenades come
in they yield grenades the guys were
diving down the stairs and we had two
guys get fragged from those
um and from that point it was like all
right you know we knew we were getting
into but then it's like now it's real
you know now our guys are getting
injured we knew we were gonna get
wounded now you got two guys wounded
with frags and their energies weren't
bad enough they had to get Medevac out
so they stayed they stayed with us you
know and it took them about three weeks
to to heal up and they're they were okay
and that was like your second op yep yep
that was like our second one
foreign
yeah yeah and then uh you know
throughout that thing there you know one
of the things I realized and this is
further down the road but we did this
this River up and we're going to set
support setting up a combat Outpost and
we're using the Marine
riverine yeah yeah unit then you guys
were awesome yeah they're awesome I
think how funny that is like hey the
Navy is supposed to deliver the Marines
yeah now the Marines are delivering us
and they were good dudes man they were
dogs they were awesome they were squared
away so they take us down river and we
had all of our deconfliction up hey
here's when we hit this point in the
water call up to the security army
security checkpoint up ahead
make sure everything's dialed in went
through all the procedures and there was
obviously a disconnect so we get close
to where we're going
and um we can see the security position
off to the right and it's on a two-story
building and we get that
we're like that's not good that's around
coming over our head from the security
position
and then we're like hey light your
strobes do your [__] and then the boat
starts speeding up a little bit to get
us to Shore and like now we're all
pissed because we just got shot at and
then we get the
you know like freaking tracers are
coming over us we're like get us to the
Shoreline man so we get to the Shoreline
and we're dumping out at that point it's
a full-on dude I just got chills I just
got chills because because when you're
taught start talking about you're
receiving fire from friendlies it's
[__] horrible and then it's a full-on
no we're not shooting back yeah but then
it's full on they think we're moves in
boats coming down the river and it's
just
we're dumping off in the thules and I'm
I'm freaking hot man so I'm dumping in
the side of the thules and we learn from
you guys hey deconflict that with your
white star cluster so I had old trusty
right here you know and as I'm going to
the Shoreline I'm popping this thing out
my weapons flying all over the place and
I'm yelling at the aoic
I was like Hey freaking call back dude
get this [__] deconflicted now and I'm
pissed I'm yelling at him I'm yelling
him he's like what the heck do you think
I'm doing what the heck do you think I'm
doing I'm like well [__] hurry up man
and so we're yelling back and forth I'm
popping up the white star cluster and of
course as soon as you get the white star
cluster up it the [__] stops yeah
um but I couldn't get to that damn thing
fast enough by the time I got it I had
it out in probably like less than 30
seconds dude 30 seconds a long time to
be receiving free fire from American
machine Gunners yeah we were all sucking
mud Mouse it was a good lesson learning
one of the things with Ramada is when
you go into a high stress environment
there's multiple units in the area the
likelihood of you having a Blue on Blue
you just go up drastically you know you
you've done a lot of podcasts with the
Vietnam [__] so when you're in those
type of environments
you've got to have your deconfliction
down you can't you can't do it enough
really yeah and you know another thing
I've been thinking about is from a
leadership perspective a thing that I've
been talking about all the time is is
like if if you if you work for me and I
come to talk to you
I gotta understand what your perspective
is like I gotta understand that so that
I can like okay he's reacting like this
because of that and and even more in
depth than that I gotta kind of know
what your freaking story is so I can't
just know your perspective I gotta know
what your story is like oh this is Steve
he's he's been here for 20 years he's
he's done a good job he also is known
for having a bad temper he also has some
trouble at home right now so I gotta
know this stuff yeah so that I can
assess like okay what approach am I
gonna take what reaction am I going to
get well guess what
when you're in a combat situation you
better think about the perspective of
the people that you're working with yeah
yeah because guess what you take a kid
that's 18 years old
scared shitless he doesn't he he's
freaking sick of being on this post he's
afraid he's gonna get killed he's not
being briefed by his seniors he's tired
he's pissed off
he's got an itchy trigger finger and
what do you think this guy's gonna do
yeah he's going to shoot at you if you
don't make it clear what's happening
yeah
so it's important to remember that you
when you you have to understand other
people's perspective and understand what
their story is and then you need to
account for that yeah somehow
otherwise bad things happen and like
that's a nightmare man like if those
those there's no protection on those
Circ boats oh I mean you're if that if
one one iteration of fire hit those
Cirque boats you'd have three four guys
dead wounded whatever maybe more yep you
got 10 guys in a boat
damn it's a nightmare yeah yeah it
wasn't good and just talking about
perspective I know the army guys
there were a couple units there that you
know they'd been there for like eight
months I want to say like eight months
and then they get the call hey you're
gonna stay like three more months oh
yeah and them dudes are wore out man I
mean they're pulling security out front
they're taking round RPG rounds they've
lost two of their friends through their
friends for their friends they've seen
VB IDs go in they've heard rumors about
boats I mean
yeah and look the army guys and the
Marines that were there the most
professional badass dudes ever ever
but there's a lot of them yeah and if
you if you have look you can have a
platoon of 40 guys and 39 of them can be
the most squared away guys you've ever
met and can understand everything and be
calm cool and collected but there's
gonna be one person in there that's not
yeah yeah and and once one person starts
shooting bro yeah it's a real problem to
get it's a real problem if you think
other people aren't gonna start shooting
as well that's that's what we literally
get trained to do oh if there's a
contact start shooting help your buddy
yeah
yeah not uh not good understandable but
uh not not a good situation we
definitely could have done a better job
on that with us
um
yeah it wasn't good we were lucky no one
got in on that one yeah yeah we had one
other Blue on Blue that I know about I'm
convincers there was I'm convincer was
probably quite a few blue on Blues going
on that you just don't you don't know
um there was because I was I was would
talk about this with the Brigade
Commander all the time there was one
there was usually one Blue on Blue per
day per day
but that that wouldn't get reported and
there was one Blue on Blue per week that
actually got reported yeah of like hey
we were taking fire from this unit at
this time most of them was like Hey
fire ceasefire you know that's a
friendly position like that happened all
it happened once a day yeah once a day
you know usually at night but the the
most harrowing example of that was there
was a Blue on Blue between Humvees
like one Humvee at night saw another
Humvee and started shooting at him and
there wasn't no moves that had Humvees
like at least the boat the boats weren't
super common to be in the river even the
Marine Corps boats they weren't super
common to be in the river so if they
rolled out someone goes oh wait a second
I don't know what this is this might be
Moosh boats let's shoot them but a
Humvee
like that's how itchy the trigger
fingers can get and you got to
understand people's perspective man we
were so freaking paranoid about that
stuff yeah yeah it was a it wasn't a
good feeling that's for sure geez and
there's nothing you can't like what are
you gonna do shoot back like you can't
do that no yeah you've grabbed that Dale
White Star cluster fired off boy damn
yeah we had one on the Blue on Blue we
were out there we were down there by
Grant Cobb Grant and uh
we went to the unit deconflicted
everything and you know our guys went
out there and were getting set up on a
rooftop and like
damn come on man yeah you know what
wasn't good but
um those high stress level areas people
are getting wounded and [__] people
don't see different things
um it's out there it's real you got to
be careful yeah when Leif and I wrote
extreme ownership like we didn't plan to
write there's three chapters in there
that are just Blue on Blue chapters yeah
out of 12 chapters yeah so a quarter of
the chapters are about Blue on Blue like
that's we didn't think about that but
that's what the reality of the situation
was those are some of the scariest you
know what's crazy is when we went back
to trade at and we incorporated our our
laser gear oh yeah people found out how
easy it is to have Blue on Blue just to
your point with perspectives like we
drew that out and it was awesome to draw
that out in training
um
but yeah
so any so after you know after those
handful Ops we had uh you know we had
November 19th and so this is putting us
you know right before Thanksgiving and
we had the whole task in it out and so
we had uh you know our cricketer guys
are up in the papa suckers our our
platoon is down
or down past Grant
I think we're down past around that area
we're about eight blocks from those guys
half mile miles something like that
maybe Juliet yeah Juliet sector yeah I
don't remember all the sectors but man
we're out there and things are going
good in like eight o'clock in the
morning we're set up we got mutually
sporting positions with arplatoon they
got mutually supporting positions with
their platoon things are good and I
remember the first thing I was like all
right this is going to be a [__] show in
here you know we had a car going around
with the the hazards on you know so
they're signally in the area hey man U.S
troops are in there but they didn't know
where we're at we didn't have any you
know loopholes we didn't pound out any
any brick or use explosives so they had
a hard time figuring out where we were
throughout the whole day
but as we're sitting there things start
heating up you know hey there's ma'ams
over two streets over and uh they're all
consulted in one area here they got
weapons and then you know hey it's
coming we're gonna get we're going to
get in the mix here
and so like around 11 o'clock we started
calling in for our our gimlers
I want to guided multiple launch rocket
system
and and we started getting that ready
commensurating coordinates to to bring
in Rockets because there's different
requirements that wasn't coming from off
the rails from the air so it was easier
to get it approved
and so as we're doing that you know we
get a call over the the radio you know
that you know our other unit from
corregidor's Hit and we didn't know how
bad they were hit but you know the aoic
came over was like Hey man Elliot said
he's in bad he's in bad shape and so is
Joe you know and we're like oh [__] man
you know they're taking them down to the
cash and [__]
which wasn't good we're like everyone
just got a sick feeling into their
stomach you know
um but we didn't know what had happened
until after we got back but we're like
[__] is he gonna make it he's not going
to make it but you know those guys were
in a position they started taking light
fire
and as they're taking light fire you
know they had rooftop Jumpers in ramadi
they'd get as close as they could and
they dump grenades right on top of your
position so the first thing that
happened is they had a grenade dumped on
their position and Ellie gets sliced in
the dam wrist pretty bad so you know
they're collapsing off down off the
rooftop and we had explosives up there
so the guys are clacking off explosives
to you know move the the rooftop jumpers
away from from their guys so as they
collapse down into
you know on the bottom floor
everything's stroll under control
there's a light barley of fire they're
calling to the other the other sniper
supporting element a we're hit we're
going to call in an extract as they're
calling an extract you know the the
Iraqis come out and our unit comes out
to get in the Bradleys
and you know they're hit with some type
of white phosphorus explosive device and
I did a lot of analysis on what that was
it a roadside bomb what was it I could
never determine what it was but you know
it killed I think three Iraqis wounded
two our two guys our two seals were hit
critically injured you know so now
they're pulling everyone back into the
house the Bradleys are getting out of
there because it's just a total [__]
show
um the other units fighting their way
down the street to get into position to
help these guys out by this by this time
um
in long story short you know everyone's
in a bad position in in L.A was such a
uh is such a good dude he's sitting
there telling dudes he's cool calm and
collect he's got [__] burning on him you
know burning through his Camis and he's
telling guys what to do to how to patch
him up and do all this [__] and he's
jacked up
um you know and Joe he had his legs kind
of blown backwards on his lower
extremities so it's a complex situation
you know outside still heated up
injured guys on the inside dead guys our
own dead guys Iraqi troops out on the
street guys fighting their ways back
down it's like as bad as the situation
is is you can conjure up right
well you know they get things under
control they call in another quick
reactionary Force they load these guys
up and you know and that's when we get
the call over the radio that though that
those guys had been hit meanwhile over
in our sector things are starting to
heat up and so we're spinning up
aircraft we're trying to get our
gamblers in position to start launching
and you know our guys are out there you
know laying down some a dub fire and
launching a few Carl Gustav Rockets into
some positions down there by us but it
was just a you know shitty day for us
you know you know obviously the whole
task unit was hit was hit hard on that
um wasn't good
yeah and I mean Elliot is probably one
of the most severely wounded seals from
the Iraq War yeah yeah he's I mean he's
he's uh a freaking Warrior yeah but he
he took a heavy hit that day yeah yeah
and you know when Elliot's story you
know that guy never quit he never gave
up on life
and um you know he's going through
physical therapy and him and his
physical therapist fall in love and
Elliot marries her they get married they
have kids
um which is just awesome you know I've
seen La a handful of times over the
years you know at Bud's graduations and
stuff like that
um
just sucks that [__] out I'm doing man
yeah and life was super good friends
with Elliot and you know obviously we
had just all high-fived on the tarmac
and said goodbye and yeah and then the
next thing that Leaf's doing he's down
at the burn center you know trying to
trying to give support to Elliot you
know it's freaking yeah freaking rough
man that [__] took the uh
that took the win out of our cell for
the whole task unit you know because
you're just wondering like what the hell
is going to happen because I know we got
two guys
uh wounded with frags you got Joan
Elliott with with what they got going on
and actually the first week we were
there you know we had Jimmy left over
from you guys he gets he got shot he
gets a grazer
um crosses nipple
so yeah things are starting to stack up
man you know and Elliott was a unknown
we weren't sure if he was going to make
it or not yeah and I left October 21st
and that was November 19th so you guys
had only been on the ground without us
for under a month yep yep and he had all
this already stacked up yep yep
yeah and not to mention in a way you are
riding in already with
the mental thought of all of our
casualties and our lost guys yeah you
know so you already know that this is
just the way yeah yeah
we had uh you know so we get past
November 19th
we're kind of reorgan and things are
starting to to change at that point I
can't remember if it was November or
December but you know we had one of the
the tribes out there they had Al Qaeda
come in and they killed a couple of
their tribes men and they were like
F Al Qaeda we want to come over the you
know U.S side and uh that was that was a
a big tip in point out their Corregidor
I forget the name of the tribe out there
but the guys went out there and they're
meeting up with the shake and their
local guys and it was a it was a weird
situation because at that point those
guys were dropping Motors on corrigador
so there's this friction like I'm
freaking helping these dudes out they
want to join us now they're just you
know the other day they're dropping
mortars on us you know
[Music]
um
so that was that was that was
interesting and then uh December time
frame we'd set up uh I think it was
right before Christmas we're we're up
there around Racetrack and uh the Marine
Corps is doing a big huge push in
through to clear out that whole area
that area was still pretty much
contested when you guys were there and
that was an area we'd operate in quite a
bit and so we're out there for like I
don't know three four days and this is
right before Christmas time we think
we're going to be out there past
Christmas and a couple of events there
like the the moves they were so good at
using Dead Space you know I remember
we're on a two-story building we got
Marine Corps snipers in position we're
in position we're spread out
and uh I go to use the bathroom and I'm
looking out this window and there's a
tank down in my corner and a dude slips
out a dead space with an RPG and like
Moosh boom he clocks that thing off in
under three seconds melts back away and
you're like even if I was on my gun I
don't think I'd had enough time to to
shoot that guy
um we had a couple close calls in that
area you know they had some snipers in
vehicles
and so it muffled the sound you couldn't
tell where they were coming from you
know and when uh you know I took a damn
shot in through our position right at
the 12 o'clock so you know we got our
loophole set up and around 762 by 54 big
one punches all the way through the wall
right at the 12 o'clock position so the
guy's Dead Center trying to get into our
hole where we're at and I just remember
thinking damn man that's whoever shot
that that's a good shot that's not you
know some JV dude making that shot
um
and as I got to tell the story I forgot
about this one but we had our country
boy old Charlie he's out now so I'll say
his name on the net but Charlie we're on
the this is all in this three four day
period
and uh we're on the rooftop and it's the
same day that I take that round and
through the 12 o'clock position and
there's Moosh doing a center peel down
the street damn and so like I'm here
Charlie's position is over here with his
crew and we got a pilot up overhead and
he's like hey you got some you got bad
guys coming down the street towards you
and you know Charlie's just a good old
country boys like Roger that you know
and he's like frag out
he dumps a frag and it like hit I don't
know how he does it he throws the frag
in the blind throws it down on the
street it hits in between where these
moves are at and the Pilot's more
excited than anyone he's like that's a
direct head that's our direct head
and I'm like talking to you I'm like
Charlie what'd you do though I'll just
pop my graduating threw it out there you
know Roger that dude but so you guys you
guys were getting aircraft overhead
inside the city
yeah we you know on the day Elliott got
hit we had a I don't know if it's a 14
or 15. okay fast movers yeah you work at
helos were you
no yeah I don't remember having any Hilo
supporter they'd be too slow they'd get
shot down yeah the heels wouldn't
wouldn't come in for us uh
because of that reason they didn't want
a freaking Black Hawk Down scenario
unfolding which is which would have
happened yeah the Apaches came in one
time and they left and didn't come back
yeah they got they got lit up like it
was crazy it was a crazy amount of
volume of fire we were putting it in a
combat Outpost and they came in they
said they want a sport they flew in and
it was like it was freaking crazy yeah
they flew away and didn't come back we
man things were so confusing over there
I remember being out there in positions
and we had
you know these two young ladies and
they're doing clothes they're hanging
clothes and then this other what looks
like the lady comes out there and she's
like laying clothes out
um
but the third person that came out late
they're just looking everywhere they're
looking for us and it was a dude dressed
like a woman you know they got the Garb
over their head so you can't even tell
but he's constantly looking looking the
girls are giggling because it's you know
it's kind of funny of them
I was like it took me a long time to put
that uh
that picture together what transpired
and I couldn't do it while I was in the
field you know I was like it was just
weird I'm like all right that had been a
dude trying to find our positions
dressed as a woman
um and these dudes were just
they were cagey man we're out there in
the papa sector on another uh Mission
and it's me and another dude and we're
set up in in the hole and uh I remember
I'm looking at a guy's looking at
looking directly at us but he's got like
a three or four year old girl right next
to him but he's looking in our Direction
I'm like that [__] ain't right but he's
got no gun he's like two three hundred
yards away I'm keeping my eye on him
watching watching watching nothing
happens me and me and the other guy
rotate out of the hole he gets in there
and [__] five minutes after he gets in
the hole we just started you know into
the hole man and like I'm young like
dude roll out of there you know he rolls
out but there's [__] flying everywhere
you know and we're like damn that was
close lucky that dude didn't get hit you
know yeah but that guy was spotting with
his daughter yeah if it even was his
daughter yeah or yes spotting with a
child spotty grabbed out and so yeah
hold my hand come over here boom yeah
and if the guy had a gun
I'd have felt comfortable taking a shot
but he doesn't have anything so you're
just like is this just more weird [__]
going on over here there's so many weird
things going on weird inexplicable
things that are happening all the time
and they're all look freaking crazy
suspicious yeah I mean we had a ISR
asset one time over go over flying
overhead like it was a fast mover or
something
and
he's like hey we got we got a vehicle
pulling up like we got a vehicle so
there everyone's looking at this vehicle
I'm looking at this vehicle on the ISR
screen and like it's this looks super
suspect they're stopping they're looking
around they get out you know open the
trunk all right oh they're opening the
trunk they're open the truck you know
everyone's on this mode and then uh
aren't they reaching and they're
reaching they're pulling something out
they're pulling something out they're
pulling out they're pulling out an
object right now and sure enough like
everyone's all excited and thinking this
is like we need to drop a bomb on this
thing and sure enough they got out of
Jack out of the thing and jacked up
their freaking car and changed the tire
and put it all away and left and like
they tracked them they left they weren't
it wasn't like a a setup you know yeah
and and man it's so difficult to to
decipher what's good really happening
yeah and you get better at it yeah
but it's a tough war to fight you know
it's a tough war to fight you know like
I know when we turned over with you guys
you always talked about the hey was a
good shoot bad result okay the what
they're doing is lined up with the Enemy
procedures
you build the story and you make the
best decision you can with what you're
looking at and sometimes just your point
it's actually legitimate but you don't
know that you know yeah well that was
something I I learned and stole from the
first the 506 because we had or they we
when we were when we first got there and
we were over with them and they had some
one of their guys shot and killed
somebody and they were like the person
was out
do I forget what suspicious activity
they were doing but it was like they
were digging a hole in the side of the
road and they shot killed the guy and
then they sent A team out there to
inspect and he was whatever uh you know
he had he was planting the plant I don't
know what he was doing but it was
something that was not the activity that
that this shooter thought it was and I
was talking to the Ops officer and he
was like hey you know what this is a
this is a good shot bad result meaning
that the got our soldier was following
the proper Rules of Engagement
and it turns out that the result of that
shot is bad even though the shot was
good the result was bad yeah and and you
know it it bothers me so much when I
hear people talk about you know these uh
the US military you know causing all
these civilian casualties man we go
through Such Great Lengths to prevent
civilian casualties and put our soldiers
Sailors Airmen and Marine at such risk
to prevent those casual so civilian
casualties from happen happening but it
does happen that's the reality like it's
going to happen and that's why if you're
gonna go to war you better be ready for
that yeah yeah you can't go to war
thinking oh yeah don't worry we won't
kill any civilians it's like you know if
you go in a war you're killing civilians
yeah
yeah I'm trying to think I know in the
other deployments I did over there we
started doing a lot of collateral damage
assessments before we did anything I
don't remember doing that when we were
in ramadi because we weren't really
dropping bombs and there was mostly just
ground
um ground units handling business you
know
um but anyways that that became a factor
later on for sure everything was a CD
you know yeah I mean even even when I
relieved you in Baghdad we started
looking at collateral damage in terms of
like breaching yeah like okay we're
gonna breach this building what's the
collateral damage could we hurt someone
can we are we going to ruin this you
know how many how many windshields are
we or how many windows in this
neighborhood are we going to blow out
with this explosive breaching charge and
what good does that do for our overall
Strategic Mission here if we're the
[__] that come in every night and
blow up everyone's house and windows
right all of a sudden we're not cool
so sometimes it was like oh okay well
maybe we shouldn't explosively breach
Weldon how are you going to execute the
mission and what risk does it put the
troops at because the safest way to do a
direct action mission is to explosively
breach the [__] out of them shock
everyone in the building and like okay
cool
so there's other tactics that we had to
develop to to mitigate the risk but what
I'm saying is we were taking risks for
sure to try and mitigate and not just us
every when I say we I mean the U.S
military at Large
mitigates risk of Civilian casualties by
risking our own casualties that's what
we do
and and even as much as we mitigate them
we can't mitigate them all and civilians
are going to die
so you need to think about that yeah
so how do when you guys had that
horrific incident with Elliot and Joe
then what then like how did the rest of
the deployment and and I know that you
guys so one thing that's really positive
is
and part of this transition I don't even
know if you knew this so we were doing
everything we could we we that whole
sons of ambar and that whole thing
started when we were there and
and then the other thing we were trying
to do is we were trying to get the Iraqi
police force built up and we just
started to get it built
as we left and so you guys got the
benefit of the Iraqi police force all of
a sudden the local Iraqi police force
was respected they were manned they had
they they understood the neighborhoods
they were tribal most the guys were
tribal guys and so all of a sudden over
a very quick period of time
the the violence went down a lot oh
absolutely absolutely I remember the
police became a huge factor I think it
was late January early February for us
they came in they were setting up their
own police stations and combat outposts
but man them dudes were targeted by AQ
you mean they had the head police chief
they're they're trying to Car Bomb him
and his entire family they eventually
got him
um but it was it was rough and it
definitely settled down everything I
would say in by the you know
mid mid January to February somewhere in
there is where things really settled in
good where hey the attacks are going way
down
you know we're still getting the
occasional IED you know like they had a
you know an army uh civil Affairs
they're going down to freaking uh Falcon
and boom they hit an ID killed all four
people oh yeah that was that was Travis
Patrick when and he's was a freaking
epic guy that and that was a major
McClung the the female Marine Corps
officer who was just because they were
there when I was there and they were
both just freaking awesome awesome
people just awesome unbelievable that
was such a freaking horrific situation
yeah it's absolutely horrible but things
definitely uh died down there towards
you know January February time frame it
was in a good place no
then you redeploy you came back to
America came back to America and boom
I'm going to work for Jocko Willie
training rolled in betrayed that man and
that was um that was awesome yeah that
was awesome did you did you volunteer to
come there what happened how did you
yeah so before deployment I know I was
working with our group CMC and they were
doing Team level detailing so he came in
he's like hey man what do you want to do
I was like well hey I want to stay out I
want to stay in the area and he's like
well what do you think about going to
trade I was like just keep me in Aaron
he's like yeah I was like hell yeah I'll
do it so Roger that man and I was
looking forward to it you know and you
know the the guy relieved over there BG
is just a good dude smart and I think he
set up a good foundation uh with with
what he had so I inherited a really
a good product yeah he was doing good
[__] yeah no it was uh it was it was
legit and then when you showed up it was
awesome
um and then
I mean what was what was your experience
at trade at like in terms of see now
this is interesting you know I told you
that like the seeds of my experience and
knowledge were watered heavily and
fertilized heavily but I was young so
now you get to experience this in a much
in a much more powerful environment
because the training we were conducting
was so much more advanced
than and also you were more advanced and
you were a combat veteran of multiple
combat tours and you were a senior
enlisted guy so man it was just it was
awesome it was a good experience but
I'll tell you what I went in there and
I'm like holy it's different when you're
responsible for a live fire range
versus you're going through a live fire
range and so there was there was a lot
to that you know the most stressful
thing for me during land Warfare was
doing all the live fire training because
there was definitely a lot of
opportunity for someone to get injured
or wounded you know you know what I mean
and so it was good and getting up there
and teaching these things you just
learned so much more I mean if the
pipeline should be
we need guys in instructor positions but
you need them a bud you also need them
over at our trade at yeah
um if there was a way to split that to
where they do 15 months it buds 15
months of trade it would be ideal
there's just it's not practical you know
um but going to trade it was an
eye-opener and I really started
you know I'd say around 2003 I started
2003 2004 started reading quite a bit
you started yeah I never heard of the
last hundred yards you know we didn't
have a portal with libraries we didn't
have guys going around if you went in a
training so you might see it
but I really started building up a good
uh reading block and I remember talking
to you when we were at trade it and we
were reading I think I just went through
the maneuver Warfare handbook and I was
like man I'm thinking these things and
then you read it and it reinforces what
you were thinking so like now your
confidence just goes through the roof
and I think one of the things we did
good in in nsw continues to do this is
developing our Future Leaders I mean
think about when you and I came up there
was no portal there was no none of this
stuff we've got stuff hanging hey you
want to be a good tactical lever leader
go read your Doctrine go read these
books here and that is going to boost
you up and the guys that are hungry
they're going to go in there and read it
the guys that are you know a little bit
lackadaisical and they don't want to do
it they're going to meet the minimum
standard but you definitely need to have
something out there to where you know
your high performers are hungry give it
to them so that they can become uh you
know a better leader so I think we did
that good but just going back to land
Warfare I think you know that the stress
levels they were high during live fire
training the field training exercises we
did were just badass we're building you
know little wood Huts all over the damn
place on those ranges and uh I think the
guys you know I mean we had a thermal
camera out there at one point and we're
videotaping the guys coming in so they
come back and go through their debrief
we're going this is what you all look
like here's what we're telling you
here's what you look like and the people
see what they look they're like oh damn
check Roger that you know they're making
some adjustments
but I thought it was good I was
definitely learning a lot while I was
there I wish I'd had done that
um that assignment earlier on in at
least the team five training so I would
have it would have boosted me up a lot
you know
would you see what did you notice from
the I mean the crazy thing about it is
you get to it's the best lat I I I I
truly think this
I think that that land Warfare training
is the best leadership laboratory in the
world I think that's it I don't think
there's a better leadership laboratory
where you can see leadership in action I
really don't because you get the whole
dynamic and someone might say well you
know in a you know in some business or
in some you know uh bureaucratic
situation or some boardroom you you get
that part too because you get the
mission planning that's taking place and
there's no gunfire going on during the
mission planning but you get the stress
and you get the people that have to make
decisions you get the team arguing with
each other and you get the different
personalities that are coming out and so
you get to watch all this and you get to
learn and you get to see how people
react and you get to see human nature
over and over and over again and you get
to see one platoon do it yeah and then
you see another do the same thing the
same I mean we had all those little uh
pet nicknames for all the different
Maneuvers that we knew that our moose
was gonna do and we so you'd see a
platoon go through the octopus you'd see
a platoon go through the corner of death
right you'd see the the Trail of Tears
you'd get to see how they would react
and you'd see what a good leader would
do
and you see how that would turn the
platoon and all of a sudden they'd be
able to get things together and survive
and make it happen and do a good job and
you'd see bad leadership and you'd go
well these guys are just it's going to
be a suffer Fest
and so that that leadership laboratory
was just unbelievably powerful and and
really it was it was powerful for for us
as instructors because we were detached
and we got to watch it look the troops
Abby obviously get a ton out of it too
but getting to see it over and over
again was just
ridiculous amount of learning one of the
things I
I really respected about land Warfare
you got to see people's true character
when they're coming through there
they're up late at night you're under a
lot of stress
whatever you're thinking in your head or
whatever type of attitude you have good
or bad that's coming out and you really
get to see what you're working with with
your platoon you know yeah and that's a
good precursor because when you go to
combat if you end up going on deployment
you end up getting in real Combat you're
gonna see that that's the only place
it's going to come out even more is when
you go into combat people start acting
crazy like and I'm not talking about hey
in a gunfighter no I'm talking about on
a day-to-day basis you start seeing what
their character is they do they want to
operate do they want to hide do they
like you get to see start to see all
that stuff and you'll see it you'll see
it out in the desert in training you'll
see people start to crack and you'll
also see people step up and you'll see
people start to lead and you see people
that are tough and when you see those
good leaders coming through and look the
good leader could be anyone in the
platoon from an E5 to the to the platoon
or the task unit Commander or anyone in
between you have one good leader or two
good leaders in there and they're gonna
do a good job yeah
they can be countered by bad leadership
so you can have a good leader that gets
countered by someone that's an ego
jackass yeah and they that ego jackass
can actually ruin everything sometimes
if you just have one good leader that's
the lpo of one platoon and he's a really
good solid leader he can carry the whole
task unit
now if you put a jackass Senior Chief in
there a jackass Chief or a jackass
Lieutenant he can he can override two or
three squared away leaders
because he's a knucklehead and doesn't
want to listen and wants to do
everything his way and wants to you know
let his ego run the show it's a freaking
disaster yeah
he saw it was funny we saw quite a few
good leaders come through probably the
most rewarding thing having guys come
through trainings are coming through
they're just starting out
as a unit you know they're figuring some
things out if they haven't been through
another block and they come in and the
growth that you see that you're
providing as instructors you know as a
Cadre as a unit
and you see him start here and by the
time they finish after that three four
weeks they're they're up here 100 the
growth is is tremendous and guess what
the heart of the training the heart of
the training the more the guys
appreciate it the more growth you have
yeah right that's what I physically saw
happening with with our with our uh
formation
yeah because it was miserable yes it was
freaking miserable it was freaking hard
when you're carrying out I mean we if if
a platoon did a bad job they'd have 12
down men
they'd be carrying out 12 down men for
three or four kilometers before they
could finally get a helicopter in there
to pick up and take the wounded then
they still got to walk the rest of them
gotta walk out like when you got your
ass kicked you got your ass kicked and
it would sometimes
you know that was another big difference
when a when a leader when the leadership
in the task unit or in the platoon would
say would come back and say hey we
screwed up we better fix it oh man yeah
they would fix it if the cake if they
came back and said oh trade that's
cheating or trade it this is this this
training is unrealistic if they said
that they wouldn't improve yeah and they
just fall apart yeah but when they say
hey
we spent too much time on target or hey
we didn't cover and move yeah or hey we
didn't give the priorities correctly or
we didn't have when they came back and
said that and recognized it fixed it
they'd come out and a good task unit
by the end our trade at guys couldn't
keep them under wraps like they would
get the trade at guys would get their
asses kicked yeah because there's
because there's 40 of the back I mean 40
of the of the platoon guys so they could
freaking they when they would do good
cover move you can't stop them no
they're Unstoppable yeah yeah well
that's what I always tell people hey man
the people who utilize the laws of
combat did good cover and move kept
things simple good Communications across
the board prioritize and executed stay
detached from what was going on and the
guys that utilize decentralized command
where they're allowing fire team leaders
and Squad leaders to make decisions at
their level because you can't be
everywhere as the boss making these
decisions you got to train your you got
to train your your leaders up
put up some guard Wheels get them to
where they need to be and then you you
let them start making decisions you know
and that that's probably like one of the
most beautiful things with land Warfare
guys are going out there they're
learning these things and they're slowly
building their confidence to where when
they get to the field training exercise
week and they start making some of these
decisions then it's even that much more
of a confidence Builder you know
it's weird because
you can you can
I mean look I would explain this stuff
ad nauseam right ad nauseum I mean I
would explain it and explain it I'd say
look you got to do this you gotta do
this you gotta do this but sometimes man
it would just take
like it happening to someone yep and
being and and me sitting there like
literally running over to a fire team
leader and saying hey what are you doing
those guys are freaking running right
now you got to get them down you got to
put down cover five for them and them
going oh wait a second I get it and then
you'd see this light come on or I'd run
up to a freaking task unit commander and
be like where do you want everyone to go
right now what do you want everyone to
do and he'd say we need to get out of
here okay what what direction
I said are you gonna be able to move
everyone out of here no can you think
your fire teams can start moving yes
tell them where you want them to move
just tell them all and they'll start
making it happen and you can see the
little like all of a sudden the little
light would come on
but sometimes it would just take that
like you have to live you almost have to
live through it yeah so in some cases
some guys would be like yeah got it
cover Move check got it because you
learn cover Move day one or day one in
the teams you learn to cover move you
better freaking cover and move yeah yeah
sometimes it took guys a little while to
figure out how to utilize the train
correctly you know because the terrain
was a was a factor Rockies small waddies
um uneven terrain which was hard to
maneuver and especially when you got a
down man
there was something there too when
Terrain
is the is the next level right the next
level
is oh I don't just know how to cover and
move I just don't know simple I just
don't know prioritize and execute I
don't just know decentralized command I
know how to utilize the terrain to my
advantage that's the next level up
that's the next level up when you
realize oh I can get a little high
ground oh there's a little dead space Oh
there's a ravine over here I can get the
guys out that's the next level and we
try to teach it in that method you know
you start off doing I ads in a flat you
know spot and then all of a sudden you
start to get used to rain but when the
leadership
when the when the pl when the whole task
unit
when a fire team leader knows how to use
Terrain and then all the fire team
leaders know how to use terrain all of a
sudden we're in a whole different spot
yeah we're in a whole different spot so
yes the terrain is so freaking critical
yeah wow
a little bit of high ground
yeah we had guys down in that micro
train doing good things yeah tough stuff
on the body
uh and we had I mean we had rain we had
Rangers out there helping us oh which
was awesome dude those guys they brought
a lot in the Rangers we had out there
they had all kinds of uh both of them
came from leadership assignments within
their their Ranger unit and they had a
lot of reps man they brought a lot to
the table they had all kinds of good
info man we were eating it we were just
like on standby Keep It Coming Keep It
Coming keep coming it's always it's one
of the the worst one of the bad things
one of the worst things about the the
SEAL Teams is
we don't come from an infantry
background yeah you know we're not
soldiers yeah we're not infantry we're
we're so we don't have that skill set
and you can get lucky and you can get
brushed up against it I got I got at
least brushed up against it doing args
with the Marines and being like okay I
at least understand what an infantry
platoon is because if you're a regular
seal new guy you don't know what the
hell an infantry platoon is you have no
idea you think a platoon is 16 guys you
know in a platoon but but yeah so those
so in the Army you have that infantry
background in the Marine Corps you have
that infantry background it's so helpful
so having like Rangers out there with us
who are freaking great guys by the way
yeah um and they bring that that
infantry background and and they were
stoked too they were they freaking love
they loved our training yeah they were
awesome and then both those guys had a
lot of reps in uh Afghanistan if I
remember right and I know where the the
one guy came in and he was really
tightening up uh
our helicopter procedures
um just you know with you covered so
much you're like damn I don't even think
about that you know all my deployments
were uh to Iraq at that point
but yeah good dudes man
did you read about face back then oh
yeah so I read it when I got to uh trade
it you know you had that as your Bible
damn what was the guy's name I had him
in here uh
there was another colonel
that uh he's got a page on four page uh
four or something in uh in about phase
but the the guy was just a beast oh
Glover Jones that's him yeah dude that
guy had so many good nuggets on that
page and a half he had yeah but I
remember reading through that page 402
half worth and he just has some nuggets
in there he's got like 15 things that he
covers you know strive to do small
things well yeah be a doer and a
self-starter
um you know the one that that I always
hit home with me because I think it's so
true is uh what is it the two
you know in order to be a good two good
characteristics of leaders you've got to
be a good communicator and you've got to
be a good uh writer and and the writing
piece comes into play as you start
moving up in your upper level leadership
and management positions because you're
writing evals for the guys and I
remember being a trade it and you were
kind of like hey man if you guys bring
me an eval and the thing requires minor
or requires major surgery I'm only going
to be able to do so much to it to make
it better but you bring me an eval
that's dialed in pretty damn tight I'm
Gonna Get It Over The Line it's gonna be
a beautiful piece of work it's going to
be a piece of art and you're getting
into people's [__] on it you were not a
happy camper because there was like all
these emails coming yeah yeah but it's
so true when you think about it hey how
do we take care of people eight way
isn't through our evaluation system
making sure the right people are getting
promoted in through Awards those all
require require some type of writing
skill right one freaking series one year
of evaluation is probably the first year
that you were there yeah this [__] that
you guys turned in and I had no choice I
didn't get him till too late and I just
had to I just had to do nine days in my
office just rewriting every single one
of them and that's why the next year
early yeah I said hey everyone write me
the eval for your best guy
and then I brought you guys you were in
this group right I brought you guys into
the into the conference room and posted
them up on the screen I made you guys
read your sentences to me and you guys
you guys were just like you know like
the very first sentence that each guy
read it would just be like uh this blah
blah this is a [__] sentence and I'd be
like all right how does that sound like
not good but that worked so well yeah
because then everyone realized oh I
should actually read this stuff I should
actually read it aloud to myself I
should actually see if these sentences
make sense and it just helped everybody
so so much helped me because now you
guys were all turning it in squared away
stuff which then I could what would you
say turn into a piece of art I don't
know if I could quite go that far I
believe in quotations a piece of art
chocolate rolling
we got an artist on the net over here
yeah uh Glover John's from hackworth too
and he wrote a book called the clay
pigeons of Saint Lo which we covered on
this podcast and it's written it's hard
to tell because he wrote it in the third
person talking about himself as if
he was a different person but it's about
him then it's a great book and it gives
all kinds of Leadership Lessons as well
um one of the things I want to camp out
real quick on uh on hackworth one of the
things as I was reading through that
book and it took me I think six months
to get through it because I think it's a
big book
but it really reinforced you know when
you're coming in is is a leader at any
level and you're new to that leadership
assignment you're always uncomfortable
so you're trying to figure out am I
making the right decision
and when you're going through and you're
reading some non-fiction that pertains
to your field your field craft
it just reinforces what you're thinking
and I remember after reading about face
the maneuver word for handbook I came
out I was like damn a lot of these
decisions I was uncertain about it
reinforced that I was making the right
decision so how do you become better you
read that stuff before you get in those
leadership positions and who's
responsible for for just throwing that
out the leadership you know if you're in
a leadership position out there what are
you doing to develop your Future Leaders
you have people that want to want to
take your your job what are you doing to
develop them and you look across the
world like we got coveted everywhere you
can get a car accident who's the next
person in line that's going to take your
job who is that person and what are you
doing to develop them you know we've
gotten way better over the years in the
military in the next W doing this
um that's you think about that it's
pretty powerful you know yeah dude JP
said because I gave I gave uh JP a copy
of at least I think I gave it to him
anyways he got a copy of the new edition
of about Facebook the forwarding and
everything and so he's like sending me
highlighted passages
and he's and he's not happy yeah and
he's like bro
I cannot believe that you didn't make me
read this when I was a you know when I
was 23 or 22. and I'm like dude I'm
sorry like I'm a horrible leader because
there's so much information in there oh
man yeah and I just ripped it off
wholesale wholesale just ripped it off
yeah and it's like
why didn't I share that yeah and and
part of me was I just didn't think Team
guys had any desire to read anything you
know because most Team guys didn't most
Team guys were like beer
you know what I did with my about face
when I got back over to when I got over
to team seven
I gave it out to one of our younger
tactical see that's like here he's like
that's a big book I'm like yes you need
to read that and then when you're done
with it you need to pass it on to
someone else do you think he read it I
don't know man it's such a big book I
don't know it's good and here's the
thing we always talk about
making hard calls you look at those
decisions he made in there those were he
was going to be hated he knew that going
in he didn't care he knew what the right
thing to do was he made the right calls
and you know he wind up saving a lot of
lives with his guys from it yeah well
see there's a little Nuance there in
what you said
he had to make hard calls
he knew that he would be hated in the
short term he knew that there would be
resistance but he knew in the end he
would be admired and he would be loved
because he would be able to keep his
guys alive and he knew that that what
what would shine through is the fact
that he cared about his men yep that's
what would shine through and believe me
when we had uh General mukayama on I was
so
uh not really worried but like going
into it here I'm going to meet a guy
that worked for a freaking hack yeah and
what is he gonna say yeah because he can
be like well you know hack would made
himself out to be a little bit more than
he was or hack talk to good game but
that really wasn't the guy he was there
I didn't know what he was going to say
yeah but dude he was just 100 100 hack
was the man and then he was a company
Commander when he when when hack was a
battalion Commander I mean that's that's
the that's the leadership wow so he you
know
well you know and I said did you know
who hack was he goes everybody knew who
hack was damn well and like that
attitude yeah and and I said you know
what how did you
what was it that made he goes everything
like the way he's carried himself the
way he looked the way he had his he had
his hair he was like he had his head
shaved and he just looked like this
guy's just freaking squared away from
day one but so you're gonna make because
because one thing I don't like and Leif
and I have talked about this on the
podcast is uh
the someone thinking well you know I'm
in charge so I'm gonna be hated and
that's okay it's like no that's actually
not okay if you're hated by your troops
that's a freaking problem that means
you're doing something wrong
for your troops for to take over a a
unit or take over a team or take over a
position
and say all right we're going to start
making some adjustments
now one thing that's different too in
hacks case when he took over the 439th
is he took over a disaster a known
disaster he had to come in there and
kind of Swing the hammer a little bit oh
he had to bring out the flamethrower
yeah he had to do some barbecue he had
to do some barbecuing but he also
eventually you know anyone would do
anything you know like talking to
General mukiyama those guys would do
absolutely anything for anything and
even the freaking even the draftees
would do anything for hackworth like
they loved him yeah and it's kind of
like you said earlier when people go
through hard training they appreciate it
and they love the training more when you
are disciplined with your troops when
you're hard on your troops they respect
you yeah and they respect themselves and
you start to get this camaraderie that
you need
you know I think a hackworth I think of
uh like you said a dude showing up right
haircut right uniform
just everything he's communicating lines
up with his actions and the guys just
had been like damn does this guy do
anything wrong you know what I mean does
he sleep what's going on with this dude
and when you look at that you're like
hey my margin of error is going to be
small because this dude's doing
everything he's saying yeah you know
it's uh powerful that's leadership by
example that's how you got to roll 100
percent
uh what anything else from trade at no
no it's all good Christmas in the desert
Christmas in the desert oh yeah yeah so
I remember uh nylon man we we were
wrapping up and we had a it was a good
run the troop came through good energy
levels
and we're getting ready to go home and
uh you came and you said
that wasn't bad guys and I was like all
right let me put that through my
enlisted decryption device up here what
Jocko's saying is good job have a good
Christmas he loves you all and you're
like cook you gave a little chuckle out
of there so I got you kind of being
Huggy Bear there right before Christmas
the spirits were good
oh so I said that wasn't bad and that's
that's as good of a compliment as you're
gonna get out of business yeah I had to
translate it for him but yeah let's
check
maybe compliments weren't my strong
point they were not
uh I got some recordings of some of
those debriefs somebody somebody's
hooking me up uh one of one of my
buddies he just texted me a a couple
weeks ago he's like hey somebody gave me
recordings of your debriefs
you're going to want to hear him like
Jack yeah I remember being on target out
there and uh this unit was maneuvering
I forget what siphon we're at but
one of the guys communication is so long
hey I need you to grab your guys and
move to the mountain like in Blackhawk
Down you're like what the hell why don't
you you know what are you talking about
man it's just crazy talk you know yeah I
would just hit record on my voice
recorder during those things and play it
back for people like listen to yourself
I think you need to keep your stuff a
little clearer more simple clear and
concise I was keeping it simple oh
really listen to this here's you telling
your troops peel right hey I need
everyone to blah blah blah blah freaking
ridiculous yeah yeah freaking totally
ridiculous yeah yeah that was crazy
so then where'd you go yep so after that
headed back over to uh our headed to
team seven and at that point it already
made Master Chief so I was going and
there's the Ops Mass Chief senior listed
guy and then I got pegged to do so I
went back there and what uh October 20
2009 October 2009 I just finished up the
senior listed Academy and they're like
hey this big one they're trying to pump
as many people as they can over in
Afghanistan so I got hit with a joint
individual augment headed out to a small
out station out in Afghanistan I was the
senior enlisted leader out there which
was a good experience it was a first
time
at that point where I really worked in a
joint environment so the my boss was a
full bird colonel he was SF dude good
guy learned a lot from him he'd been in
like 32 years he was Prior enlisted and
she worked his way up through the ranks
just salty old dog
um and then we had you know the Army Air
Force uh Marine Corps out there everyone
and then we had you know quite a few
Military Officers from different
countries you know we had Afghanistan
and a few other surrounding countries in
there
um in in our our primary goal was to
Fusion Intel and then you know we had
some reconnaissance platforms up
overhead and you know they were doing
their doing their stuff in some other
countries but it was good and uh that
was the first time I really appreciated
our Special Forces Unit
and I was working with another senior
enlisted leader he was in another
country and he's like hey man here's
what we got going on and me and him
would communicate back and forth you
know like once or twice a week he's like
hey I got my SF Battalion we're training
up this and he's like here's our numbers
and I was like hey wait a minute you
guys have this many you know odas over
there and you've trained up you've man
trained and equipped 2 000 of these
soldiers he's like yeah and I was like
holy [__] dude that's a big deal man
that's like our formation in his W in
action over there you know yeah like by
that you mean all of the West Coast seal
and all support yeah in action yeah and
so these guys are training up these guys
and they're going in and they're
fighting the Taliban and he's got his
odas doing I was like holy [__] that's
uh pretty badass man
um so it was a good deployment like not
much going on outside the wire the area
I was in was actually like yeah I was
like cool I just got out an island then
I go over there and I'm like damn I'm
back in Ireland the terrain is exactly
the same
there was some Hub Hub about us losing
our desert training facility someone
else was going to take it over oh yeah
and I made these this slide show did I
ever show you that I made a slideshow
and it was pictures of Afghanistan and
pictures of our desert training facility
side by side and you literally couldn't
tell the difference wow and I was like
you've got to be kidding me if you think
that this isn't the greatest training
site for for us to have yeah yeah yeah
so anyways that was a short appointment
at that point on the Ops master chief
that I'm deployed come back uh six
months later I got home right before
July and then as I'm back at the team
the team's going through unit Level
Training and then we're prepping up for
our deployment in uh March time frame
and that was a weird deployment like we
wanted some of us wound up back over in
Iraq and so this is 2010 2011 time frame
now and we're breaking down Iraq yes but
then we're also yeah we're waiting for
our four platoons that are still in San
Diego to get over to Afghanistan and
they're going over to do Village
stability operations
so
get over to Iraq and that you know that
deployment
um it was a long one it was like eight
eight and a half months long
um a lot of you know the unit we were
working with had all the bells and
whistles and it was good man so a lot of
good things happening um our guys
wrapped up quite a few bad guys and uh
it was it was a good learning experience
it was the first time I was in
you know a professional jock setting
where you're actually seeing everything
unfold in real time all the assets you
can imagine
um you know and our guys did some good
targeting they got a couple bad guys
have been after for four or five years
so it was good and came back off that
deployment and took over as the team you
know command master chief so explain
what a team command master chief is
well our primary job is to initially is
to set up the batons you're working with
the you know the top five of the team
the commanding officer the XO your
operations Department you know the
senior listed in there and the and the
Ops boss
um
and your primary functions are Manning
training and equipping the Civil team
and you're the senior enlisted leader
um and tactical advisor to the
commanding officer their primary goal is
training up all these you're not
training uh educating and training you
know your uh your platoon Chiefs and
task unit uh senior enlisted advisors
and Junior officers and so you take over
this position and you start building
platoons yeah yeah and I always used to
say about platoons let's say there's a
magic number let's say the number number
is
20. yeah in your top four in a platoon
so your lpo your assistant platoon
Commander your platoon commander and
your platoon chief that number's gotta
equal 20. when you add them all together
yeah yeah so that means if you have a
a a a a platoon Chief that's like a 16
because he's just a badass cool you can
give him a platoon Commander that's like
a two and a lpo that's a one if you have
a platoon Chief that's like a you know
maybe a six but you got to give him a
platoon Commander that's maybe like a
seven and you gotta even it out yeah
what you don't want to do is make sure
first of all you got to make sure that
the number gets to 20.
because if it doesn't get to 20 you're
going to have issues uh then then you
got to complement strengths and
weaknesses you know if you've got a guy
that's got a bunch of tactical
experience but he's horrible at
paperwork well cool you know uh put him
with a person that's good good paperwork
so there's a lot of balancing in in
there that you need to do absolutely and
I know uh our 20 when we formed up the
team in 2010 we went with some heavy
platoons with the idea we're going to go
back in Afghanistan
and and one of the things with our our
training and deployment schedule is that
there's a lot of lag time in there so
things are always changing and I was
like man when we get back and I'm
forming up the team I want to make sure
just to your point all these platoons
are balanced out
um you know when you go heavy in some
platoons that means you're going to be
lighting the others yeah and that comes
that comes at a cost and really what I
wanted was
you got however many platoons you have
at a sales team you should be able to
pick up any one of those platoons and
snap them in no matter where you know
where you're going what the mission is
they should all be pretty balanced out
equally with experience in the platoon
leadership yeah you check and here's
another thing to be careful of
to watch out for you you're trying to
get to 20. don't build a platoon with a
leadership level 40. yeah because it's
probably not going to work the way you
think it is what you're going to end up
with is a bunch of big personalities
like you take the strongest possible OIC
the strongest possible Chief the
strongest possible uh lpo and the
strongest what you're going to end up
with is people that will they all want
to freaking stab each other in the back
they all want to be the guy they all
want to they have such big Egos and it
just turns into a nightmare yeah so
building the Stacked platoon leadership
is generally not a good call and you're
good even even if it happened if you
actually had such exceptional
individuals that they actually did work
well together
that well then you're it's bad that you
have them all together because like you
said now you're not balancing out the
rest of the teams because because you
should take those exceptionally because
for for a for a level 20 individual
leader actually for for a level 17
individual leader
to work with another high performing
leader that other leader needs to be a
20. yeah because that the person that's
a 20 and 20 instead of a 17 the
difference between a 17 and a 20 is that
17 can
can subordinate their ego that's the
difference because when you take two
people that are 18s they're missing
quality that they don't have is that
they don't they don't know how to work
with other people and subordinate their
ego that's what gets you to a freaking
level 20 yourself yeah yeah
the balanced out platoons are are key
for the entire team it's goodness and
you think about it so if I'm bringing in
a platoon and you know we really spread
out our guys with with two and three
platoons because those guys are
developing the next set of leaders below
them you know the platoon Chief and lpo
and everyone's got to develop the other
guys too but those guys have the most
impact when the leadership's gone
they're the guys that are around and
they're showing them what right looks
like so we cross-dicked you know quite a
few guys got everything uh balanced out
good and overall you know our deployment
was uneventful for that one went over to
centcom
um
and we were on standby to standby you
know that was after Benghazi and happy
so The New Normal was hey be on standby
in case there's a crisis in there if
crisis comes up we want to have Special
Operations posture to go handle an
embassy type event
um and it was good so for that
deployment we winded up you know in and
out of the embassy quite a bit which was
good because that I was like oh I've
never been in an embassy before so
you're talking directly to the
Ambassador and a whole new world yeah
and you got to be professional you got
to have your suit on and you know you
can't drop any f-bombs out there it's
yeah it's a whole new world yeah so it
was a really good learning experience
although nothing happened and I'll say
this we got postured you know we had a
a unit over into a neighboring country
and that country was you know uh they
were going through a withdrawal process
and our units still stayed in position
but we were going to reinforce that unit
so we were staged we had to Stage so we
brought in the aircraft which you know
we're going through a full-blown
rehearsal like we're thinking we're
going to launch our guys
and
you know our my biggest takeaway from
that the point was like hey these
relationships we have with the embassy
they matter because all we had to do was
call up there because we had a tight
relationship and they tell us hey here's
what's going on the ambassador's working
with the prince and the prince and
they're going through this whole thing
do we want to launch out of here do we
not want to launch out of here
um so he it was good you know it was
boring but it was a good learning
experience yeah and for for people that
don't uh really know too much about this
world there there can be and usually is
a lot of tension between the state
department which is the ambassadors and
whatnot and the military yeah because
the state department wants to solve
things diplomatically yeah that's what
their life is right and the military we
think we can solve things militarily so
there's tension yeah there's often
tension between those two sides but if
you remember that hey we all have the
same goal right we all have the goal of
stability and security and and overall
Peace So if we understand that we're
working towards the same goal let's
figure out the best way to go about it
and those tensions hopefully we can
overcome yeah because they can cause
they can cause some really bad things to
happen you know there can be times where
the military should be used
and if the relationship was good the
military would be used yeah and there's
some times where the military shouldn't
be used and if the relationship is bad
the military gets used even though it
really shouldn't be used yeah so once
again forming good relationships is
just freaking critical no absolutely
especially in that environment more so
than than ever you know hey going back
into when we were forming up you know
one of the first things we did
is you know what grabbed in our goat
Locker you know our our enlisted uh
formation e79 and we went through roles
and responsibilities in the CMC I had at
the time when I was my task unit uh when
I was attaching a seniorist advisor he'd
went through and I don't know how much
you played into the roles and
responsibilities he developed or or if
they cross-decked or what but he went
through every position so I'd already
had something that I'd kept for geez
what is this uh four years now four or
five years later and I've got it and I
go through and I'm I'm tweaking the
verbiage in there to fit to you know to
Art to our air our time got it yeah and
so go through roles and responsibilities
with the goat locker and our tactical
level leaders hey here's my expectations
as a leader and and we had your Jocko
brief on there so I had a little reading
folder on our Drive here's what's in
there read this [__] it's going to make
you a better leader and I think for the
most part our guys did like we didn't
have too many missteps for that
um for that work up cycle and deployment
you know things were relatively
contained you know like you know kooky
[__]
no big events yes setting expectations
is definitely solid and in the in the
seal version of the Jocko brief there's
a slide that was roles and
responsibilities by person yep like
task unit Commander here's what you're
doing and I went right on down the line
and I'm sure you guys had to adjust it
too but the point is and the reason I
don't give it really in the Civil
because I don't give it I don't give
roles and responsibilities part of the
brief because I don't know what the
roles and responsibilities are in this
construction company or in this
manufacturing company or in this
financial company right it changes it
shifts but in the in the seal platoon in
a seal task unit I knew what the rules
and responsibilities were and listen and
here's something I used to explain like
if you're
the platoon chief
and you're supposed to be the the person
that's handling the Tactical situation
okay if the officer is supposed to be
looking at the next move that we're
going to take Hey listen Chief if your
officer is not capable of doing that
you better get your lpo trained up so he
can handle the Tactical situation so you
can go and and figure out what you're
going to do next so so we have to be
able to not just do like our specific
job our role and responsibility but if
we have to inside of our platoon we
might have to say hey you know what
Chief you handle this over here you know
if I got a chief that's not super
Dynamic On Target and I got an lpo
that's a badass I'll go hey hey lpo
you're gonna be you're gonna you're
gonna be responsible for this stuff
you're going to be responsible for the
assault Chief you're going to be
responsible for the marshalling yeah
okay cool got it you're like that's okay
it doesn't matter now don't let your ego
get in the way yeah because it's cheap
well I'm supposed to be in charge of the
assault cool you're not good at it yeah
of course I'd be much more gentle about
it what I would say is hey you know well
the thing is I want the lpo to get some
experience so we're going to let him
handle some of these right now and see
how he does and in the meantime you can
just kind of handle the marshalling over
here you know with the with the aoic so
but yeah those roles responsible ability
so the fact that you laid those out
early lets everyone know what the
expectation is lets everybody know where
you stand right lets everybody know like
hey I don't put up I'm not going to put
up with this I'm not going to put up
with that I'm not going to put up with
the other thing yeah if you're out of
line come you better come and tell me
what's going on if I get blindsided
you're gonna be problems so all those
all those things absolutely like
that's a great Point setting those
expectations
of what you ex what what you need what
you want what your standards are you set
those out of the gate it's going to
align people real quick yeah and then
you model them you got to model them
yeah you got to do what you're saying oh
yeah if you're if you're not you might
as well just freaking
just not even put out the word if you're
gonna say hey everyone be squared away
and you're gonna act like a jackass just
don't even put it out you know it just
clears everybody else
dumb move uh and then what and then what
so finish up that deployment come back
and then I go and work at our
headquarters for our uh Force Master
Chief which was an awesome guy at the
time learned a truckload from him which
I'd would have tried to be able to use
for my next two positions and so at the
headquarters element you know what I
have on there
let's go back one real quick the
headquarters element was was good
because it was the first time I'm
outside of that
that Seal Team you know whether it's
training or just single you know
um
Mission Europe at the headquarters
element you know I was in the same
office year but I'm working for the
force you're working for the Admiral so
it's a very similar line did you do how
long did you worked there for uh right
around less than a year and a half got
it but it was enough are we ready to get
out of there after 12 hours but here's
what I would say I wished I would have
done that position earlier on probably
like as a chief or a Senior Chief but
what does right look like where does it
fit the training I think would have
priority because that's going to set you
up tactically
but going up there you're like holy cow
your aperture just opens wide up with
actually how things work you know with
uh with seal platoons going over into
Afghanistan into Iraq how all that stuff
works that you want more gear here's the
here's the process to procure the gear
and you're going through all that and
one of the things
the guy I work for did is he was up
there and he like he laid out
initiatives hey here's the initiatives I
want to get over the line and then I was
the guy you know when he's on travel
back at the the black Palace trying to
move these things forward as you know as
quickly as possible without missing
anything so it was it was a good
experience and the guy worked for he had
over 30 years and he bounced around just
he was a good dude man yeah I learned a
lot from him yeah well you're right I
did work we worked in the exact same
front they call it the front office and
and for sure when you start to see
you start to see
how small of a role right like
you're small there's like there's like
the whole military that's the first time
you get a taste of like did you go to
the Pentagon did you go on travel with
your boss I went back to uh Socom I
didn't travel that much with those guys
so I was going to the Panic bro the
Pentagon yeah I was I was I was you know
sitting in in the back in the back of
the meeting with Socom you know over and
over again and hearing the word being
put out and seeing them seeing that the
handwritten notes from the Secretary of
Defense yeah you know what I'm saying
like
all of a sudden you realize how big this
machine is yeah
and and that puts things in perspective
for you and yes you learn a lot about
you know how to make things happen and
how well not how to make things happen
but how things happen yes and then you
can at least provide some level of
influence on trying to hopefully make
things happen yourself
because that's a big understanding it
makes all the difference in the world
because now you know how to navigate it
yeah and you also know like I'm there's
no point getting frustrated about this
thing over here because I can at least
explain to the Troops hey this is why
this is happening I know it seems crazy
but guess what the money that's getting
spent for weapons right now was actually
allocated five years ago yeah yeah
and so if you're going to be mad about
it that's fine but it's not going to
help yeah
that and that was issues I remember we
were getting gear three four years later
that was designed for the previous three
four years and it was already obsolete
you're like I don't I can't even use
this stuff right now you know
but it was good and I remember being up
there in 2015 and I think that was when
you and Leif sent your first published
copy of extreme ownership up there for
approval oh yeah well then it wasn't a
published copy it was probably like a
manuscript that's what it was so I got
me a copy of that oh really got the
early one I got the early one so I read
through I didn't know what to expect you
know and back then everyone's going hey
man people are on their net writing
books I'm like let's see what Jocko and
labor right about here a little courtesy
copy and I remember picking up my
reading I'm like damn this is really
good because the way you guys translated
into the business world was just you
know it made sense you know so and plus
you recognized it all yeah from from the
Jocko brief which is yeah you know
basically where it all came from yeah
yeah and your guys at the way you wrote
it the position on it was from a
humility standpoint which people are
going to appreciate that so it was good
man yeah I know that was uh that was a
big
um obstacle to overcome mentally yeah
you know like
uh for me it was massive you know I
can't speak for life but like for me I
mean we just talked opened this whole
thing up about talking about reputation
yeah and all of a sudden you know you
can you can destroy your reputation by
becoming that guy yeah who wrote that
book and you know and and yeah so that
was horrible that was a horrible uh
experience to go through it's like
walking into the unknown and you can't
look and you can't
there's look when you write a book
it is not a humble act right like
there's no there's it's like saying hey
I'm gonna go freaking uh uh starting a
podcast get a designer suit yeah or
start a podcast hey I'm gonna go get a
designer suit but it's not for it's not
for me yeah like it doesn't work or hey
I'm gonna start a podcast and talk a
bunch like what do you got to talk about
dude so to say you're gonna write a book
or you're going to start a podcast or
you're gonna put a spotlight on yourself
is basically what you're doing that's
that's what I'm saying right when you
write a book you're putting a spotlight
on yourself look at me yeah and and
there's no it doesn't matter what that
book says yeah
at least at the initial impression like
you you you you are putting a spotlight
on yourself and I hated that and it was
really it was hard to overcome that yeah
but then you think here we are working
with these civilian companies yeah and
they are
being able to move forward and execute
better and it's like you know what
the stuff that we learned is probably
worth teaching yeah yeah the stuff that
we learned is people need to hear it and
then uh one of the the Admiral
uh you know to kind of have that kind of
conversation with him and he says he
said uh he goes you know what Jocko
we are quiet professionals we are not
silent professionals and some of the
stories need to be told and some of the
lessons need to be taught yeah and the
way you're doing it
is the way it should be done yeah and
and that was real um
you know obviously that was about as
much reassurance as I could get and then
and then you know just having uh having
friends that read the book in the in the
teams and were like bro legit and then
and then same thing with the podcast
like when I started bro when I started
with the podcast with all my friends
started like call me like dude that
podcast was sick and everyone like
that's when I was super stoked you know
because you feel horrible uh and you
feel like you're shining a spotlight on
yourself and what I realized
was that people saw it I was actually
trying to sign a spotlight not on me but
like on
the community not even just our
community but the Army the the Marine
Corps like every every one that is out
there working hard is where where the
spotlight was trying to be shined it's
just that I happen to hold it yeah it's
pretty sketchy to pick that thing up Bro
think about this think about
if there were podcasts going on in the
90s when we were coming up where we
could learn and go and get information
on books to read and lessons learned
from people that were in Vietnam that
are talking hey here's some things we
jacked up we had a Blue on Blue I wish
I'd have done this here's what I did as
a leader that was jacked up I wish I
would have you know came over and talked
to echo on this thing I mean how much
better would we have been we didn't have
we had enough man we had nothing and and
that's
um believe me I think about that all the
time I mean even when I when Mike
Thornton came on yeah and and we did a
full debrief I was like I was in the
SEAL Teams for 20 years yeah and I never
got that debrief I never read that
debrief never saw never didn't know all
those lessons that he learned yeah yeah
and it's like wait a second that's so
wrong I felt horrible yeah and so you
know what now it's like oh you can bring
on Roger Hayden because Roger Hayden
taught me stuff yeah but how is a new
guy gonna learn about Roger Hayden and
his lessons yeah yeah you know and it's
not even just lessons about hey cover
move or hey keep it simple it's lessons
about hey when this happens
when you lose a guy when you get a guy
badly wounded when you get somebody
that's you know acting a certain way
when someone's losing in combat like all
those lessons yeah yeah being able to to
learn them is freaking so powerful yeah
it only help people out in the future
you know it's good I mean when I had
James Webb on uh who is you know Naval
Academy Marine Corps Navy cross uh you
know Secretary of the Navy
but when we got done and I mean he he he
wrote the book uh fields of fire
Incredible Book and it's sort of the
book that all Vietnam movies are based
on yeah all every movie about Vietnam is
based on that book in one way or another
and it's based and that book is is a
thinly disguised autobiography
but when we got done we walked out and
he was like I never got debriefed like
that no one ever debriefed anything
anything that I did in Vietnam like that
wow and he goes you know I wrote there's
some stuff written down in some library
in the 12th floor of the Pentagon you
know row 17 Alpha because no one's ever
going to read that and and to be able to
debrief like that
it's yeah he's like thank you and and
his son was in freaking ramadi wow wow
so yeah there's a I I'm I'm saying do
believe me I mean I meet I meet Marines
and army guys and Team guys all the time
they're like oh yeah episode this
episode is freaking awesome because just
what you just said we didn't get that
opportunity to be able to get the
debriefs from people and hear these
lessons yeah and it's
so we're so lucky to be able to do that
it's a powerful learning tool you know a
lot of things you do just to your point
in the military translate right over
into the business world for everyone to
learn from you know
so then once you get done you got done
with warcom what happened so got done
with the work on and uh went over and uh
at that time we were doing rotations
with uh combined joint Special
Operations task force task force that
goes into Iraq and then you know the
deal with the siege of soda you know
they're in charge of the maneuver
elements Yeah so basically this is a
group that's in charge of all the
special operations in a area in this
case Iraq yeah yep yep so went up there
and I think we had you know you're
working with all these other countries
and they're reporting to you we're
working together as one big team one big
unit I think we had in between 800 and
1100 people with the siege of soda from
guys are dispersed to everyone this is a
a point in Iraq where you know Isis has
a foothold up in mosul and we've got you
know it was the first time I actually
worked with uh marsok we had uh their
msots and their M sock out there along
with the o5 headquarters they were up
north and we had our nsw unit and they
were co-located with us
um
there in Baghdad and so it was a it was
a good experience you know and we're
figuring out hey how are we gonna take
take uh down mosul you know there's been
several rotations before it's where
everyone's just waiting one of the rack
he's going to want to do it one of the
rack is going to want to do it and uh
that came to a head on our deployment
which was good
um and so finally we get approval guys
come in there and so what year is this
this is 2016.
2016. so you know uh guys going there
and start clearing out mosul you know
and at some point you know one of our
seal units rotated out and Jay and his
formation rotated in which is awesome
JJ's team was was awesome having his uh
commanding officer did a great job
building that out you know they were it
was a you know one of the best SEAL
Teams I'd I'd seen
um so it was good anyway say come in and
start clearing mosul me and my boss we
push up to uh or Bill and then adder or
Bill we were running a small jock out of
there so we were co-located with
God I forget the sea Jog and the Sea
jock was the one who could clear
airspace to drop Ordnance and we needed
to be co-located with them to help
deconflict in case anything got snagged
up
um
so anyways there was a lot of kinetic
fighting in there going on at that point
but a good experience we're working with
I think seven or eight different
countries first time I've been inside a
sea just sort of working like that and
you're up in the upper leadership and
management position you know taking on
everything that's going on I'm trying to
provide my my boss with the the best
advice I can on you know what I
recommend
um you know in the in the boss I had
back then he's an admiral now but he was
just
squared away just even tempered guy
people loved him the other countries
love them like hey where'd you get this
guy I'm like that's my first time
working but he's dialed in he had a
great reputation you know
um so it was it was it was a good
deployment you know and probably the
things that weighed the most on that
deployment
is I'd never really been a part of a
ramp ceremony to where you're like
you're leading this thing and uh
we had one of our warrant officers and
this was our first ramp ceremony
so we had a pilot that was shot down I
want to say it was 2006 time period and
his remains were never recovered
and our warrant officer went off this
and he's working with a shake the
Shake's going hey we got the remains if
you want them and they start doing
negotiations and then shakes like hey we
want this amount of money and our guys
going back and forth
and and just a point up front I want to
make is when you assign the right person
you know the right talent to that to
what you're trying to accomplish you can
get a lot over the finish line
and I'm seeing that up front because
there was other agencies that had worked
with this shake to try to get the
remains back they couldn't get it over
the finish line but here was a guy with
never done this before the right
temperament the right attitude went in
there and was playing a little Hardball
with this guy played a little softball
over here and he got it over the Finish
Line you know he wanted a you know you
know
negotiating with the shake we got the
remains back we went through our ramp
ceremony back here and then we got the
you know the remains back to the U.S so
the you know that officer could be
properly uh buried and he was he was a a
pilot that had been shot down
so
it was powerful felt good you know felt
good and then we had a few other ramp
ceremonies we know we lost uh this was
one of one of jay-zod's Bubbas but he
was hit you know up there in mosul with
an IED and he was killed and so we did a
ramp ceremony film and brought him back
and uh we had one other guy and I want
to I'll tie this back into ramadi but
the the third guy we had he was you know
he's doing some stuff in another country
he was hit hard he was killed
and we brought him back to us and it was
like the night before Thanksgiving back
in the U.S
and in ramadi we were operating right
before Christmas and you know the siege
of social Commander pulled us out and we
were pissed off we were like what the
hell man we were planning on being here
in through Christmas Eve and through
Christmas in The Siege associative
Commander back in 2006 said hey man I
don't want to report back to anyone's
family that their son was wounded or
killed you know before Christmas and
then here we are you know damn near 10
years later in in Iraq and this guy gets
killed right before Thanksgiving and his
family's over with the other family or
his wife and kids are over with their
family and they got to get notified
we're coming back here going through all
our procedures to make sure everything's
tight and he's getting his uh proper
respect before we send him out
but those things like when you're
putting an American on an aircraft in a
casket with the flag draped over man it
just it's a gut punch man it sucks it
sucks man it's something I never you
know wish upon anyone
um and it really hits home dude to you
you know not good
how long was that deployment that was a
sexual author
and the Iraqis took massive casualties
before we left they were like the
special unit we were working with and it
trained up over the years the the SF
actually trained him well if I think we
had a hand in the pie somewhere in there
but
they were dialed in they were the best
unit that the Iraqis had and these guys
had a lot of Pride but they were like
over 800 casualties uh when we left and
it was just it was
I mean Isis was no joke over there man
they were they're barbaric brutal and
you know there's a
there's a fraction of of people where
you think you're going to come in you're
going to talk some sense into some
people like that you're not you're not
talking to them and if they get a hold
of you it's not going to be good for you
you're going to get your head chopped
off
and that's the type of uh that's what
that's what we're dealing with over
there and those you know that unit that
our guys were working with
they laid it all out there they're going
in there for their country for Iraq to
secure that City to make it a better
place and man they took heavy casualties
I mean heavy casualties
um you know the the
truck bombs they built from 2004 to 2016
they up armored them in 2016. so when
they're coming at you there's no way
there's not a good way to defeat them
you need some type of missile system or
rocket system coming in on top
or you need some type of a resting
device to where you can stop the vehicle
from coming at you
um you know we had some good penetration
with some of our heavy caliber weapons
was stopping them but it was hard it was
not easy and they'd hide them underneath
you know vehicle or or carport
um entry points and you wouldn't be able
to tell what it is the next thing you
know that big huge you know truck bomb
is on the move and there's up armored
all over the place and there's just a
small window that they can look out and
guess what if they come off the seat or
anything happens with the seat in their
adjustment the thing's rigged to just
blow so as soon as it hits something the
whole thing's going up and man we just
remember watching CTS units this damn
thing to be coming you'd be trying to
call in an airstrike but you got like a
minute and 30 seconds to clear air space
overhead to get bombs down on targets
it's like it wasn't going to happen so
you had to be able to handle business as
a Tactical Unit on the ground to take
this thing out you know we give these
guys rockets and ship but it they
weren't effective so it was a super
complex and frustrating
um environment you know and took a lot
of casualties yeah I know uh Jason was
saying that that you know at a certain
point they were thinking that the Iraqi
unit that was doing the majority of the
fighting was just going to run out of
guys like they just were gonna they were
just gonna all be dead or all be
casualties which is which was freaking
scary and I I was horrified you know
when he was telling me that no it's I
was hearing some of that while while you
guys were actually over there
but at the same time even though it kind
of horrified me at the same time I also
was
this is going to sound wrong but I was
happy to hear it because what it told me
was that the Iraqis were fighting yeah
and
when we were in ramadi the Iraqis
they they some of them would fight but
it definitely wasn't they weren't
looking to take massive casualties to
try and take a city back like they
didn't care that much yeah and they
would run away we had a whole Battalion
quit a whole Battalion of Iraqi soldiers
said yeah we're out yeah well we had one
entire company disappear like there was
a a strike on there on one of their
checkpoints and they all just bailed
that was that yeah so to hear how hard
the Iraqis were fighting and they were
taking it to Isis and that they were
staying in the fight that was just
freaking um that was just it was awesome
to hear that it was so horrible to hear
that they were taking casualties but it
was great to hear that they had found
the will to fight and that they were
Unified
and and fighting courageously to to
liberate other Iraqis inside their
country from these actual Savages that
are doing the most committing the most
heinous atrocities imaginable and and it
was all it was awesome to hear that they
were that they were fighting like that
and and it was also you know when when
Isis decided to
you know wear a uniform and put up Flags
it was like right on let's see how this
works out for you
yeah freaking legit uh
and then what then what so finish up
with with that deployment get back off
of that and then that's when I rolled
over to group one
so you know started you know I got a
good six
th month of getting saturated with group
level stuff and you know with the group
you're responsible for all you know four
West Coast SEAL Teams and three other
commands so you got roughly right around
1800 people or so
um and your primary function there is
Manning training and equipment so I'm
working directly with the team command
master Chiefs
um on some occasions they're commanding
officers and so you're in a position of
a lot of influence at that point you
know and I'm directly working with our
Commodore on on our initiatives and
moving the mission forward
and you're also dealing with uh whatever
sort of you know equipment like trying
to get equipment for the guys trying to
just the whole nine yards and and
overall
responsible for their training
did you go out to the desert during that
time went out there a couple times damn
bro and it's so it's weird it's
different when you're up at that level
when you come down in it's never the
same yeah it's never you know you're the
gun show for you yeah you're the guy
then it's like hey I'm coming in there
to see this and you're like hey man you
guys might want to tighten this [__] up
over here you know but um it was good
you know uh damn who was there I think
Jay yeah Jay was it trade it at the time
so it was good so Jay was always there
as a right-hand man I had out there and
we had a good crew of uh Team committed
Master Chiefs and one of the things we
started doing back in 2015 with the the
force I was working with the force
command Mass Chief is he started
implementing a screening process so we
were basically going through a hiring to
make sure that we were getting the right
leaders in at the the master chief level
to take over some of these command
positions and it's not perfect but it
was a hell of a lot better than where we
were
um they also we also started
implementing in you know platoon Chief
and task unit senior list advisor
screening and that was developing so
it's uh it's getting better as we move
forward bottom line is you know things
are getting better you're moving things
forward that's what you want um for a
better formation
you know and just going back to work on
real quick
one of the things I realized when you're
up there you know when you're down in
the troops you're just like give me my
gear I want to get go to war and do all
these things and people talk a lot of
[__] about everyone above them
and here's the deal with the people that
are above you
I'm you I'm you I was the E5 talking
that [__] saying all those things and
guess what I moved up positions but I
moved up in positions to take care of
people right and so there's a lot of
kooky things that come out you're the
guy behind the scenes squashing these
things you know to make sure that that
our people are taken care of
and I was I had a buddy that was you
know he was a hard case and he's like
hey man won't you ever see this why
don't you you need to stand up and say
something about that I'm like hey man
I'm handling that [__] behind closed
doors I'm not going to come here and
open Forum with the commander and
disagree with them in front of all these
people man that's not that's not smart
I'm getting nowhere yeah but if I come
around the backside here do a little
flank plant some seeds you can have a
lot more influence that way
um so anyways you're always going to get
that [__] with the hard cases you know
what I'm talking about yeah and then how
long was that tour so that was a
two-year tour you know and I wanted to
finish up my career there and and and
towards the end you're like I mean what
what were you thinking what was on the
horizon and what was your
decision-making process to to decide to
punch punch yeah so I punched right at
like the 28 and a half year mark so I
could have gone another year and a half
but man I was out of juice and one of
the things people talk about is hey you
know when it's time to go and man I was
in that position and we had some high
profile cases out there and they just
wear on you man you know they just wear
on you and even before that happened I
knew it was time for me to go I'm like
all right I'm gonna do this position
it's time for me to to move out of here
I don't think I had anything left to add
value to the mission in the organization
I was topped out with my leadership
capacity and we have plenty of guys that
go out there and do the the T socks you
know the theater Special Operations
Command and that's a high level of
influence those are Action Arms in the
operational uh areas and I was like man
I just don't see myself going and
working at that level you're working
with General officers with Admirals and
I was like man I just I was up at warcom
kind of got a a little bit of a taste of
that and I was like that's just not
um and we need people to do those
positions so we had quite a few East
Coast guys go in and uh and and into
those t-soc positions did you need them
because that's a huge a high level of
influence that the that we have in nsw
if you have your guy in there he can
help influence some outcomes which is
super important but I was definitely
maxed out uh out of gas uh time for me
to pack up and go home
and one of the things that always uh it
comes to mind with me is in 2003 you
know we had Posey Out There Our Vietnam
guy good dude man good Family Guy
Vietnam had more stories you can imagine
but
he was like man Steve you guys are
stronger faster smarter than than we
ever were I was like damn what's he
talking about and then I look back you
know 28 you know 15 years later whatever
it was
and I'm like these young guys that are
coming in they're hungry they're smarter
they're Stronger Than I Was they're
faster than I was
meaning hey the community's in a good
spot we got our next Generation coming
up in through our ranks doing good
things
you know one of the things uh
one of our head leaders for the Navy put
out Mick Pond Stevens he said hey work
hard stay out of trouble and be a good
person that's all I'm asking the
formation to do the entire Navy that's
that was his Mantra work hard Seattle
trouble being good and cute be a good
and decent human being be a good person
and I never knew what the hell he meant
by stay out of trouble and then you know
as you start moving up in these
positions and you have high profile
cases and things going on
they can bring your entire Community
down to its knees meaning it's hard to
move initiatives forward it's hard to to
focus on what your actual job is because
you're dealing with you know njp you're
dealing with court martials all those
things weigh on you and it's never good
and my boss in 2015 or Force he he
hammered it home to me and it made sense
he said hey Steve we've got to protect
the mission we've got to protect our
credibility credibility that's built in
other people's blood it was spilled in
other people's blood we've got to
protect that at all cost and he's like
it's hard for us to protect the Homeland
if we if our credibility is damaged and
we can't get employed overseas to wrap
up bad guys and I was like yeah check
that [__] makes sense
um so yeah yeah well that's it's the
same thing as a reputation right yeah
the community has a reputation and
you've got to do everything you can to
protect that reputation yeah because if
you're if you're
yeah just that's just what you have to
do yeah yeah and you do your best you do
everything you can to protect your
reputation I mean that's just what you
got to do you know
man
any other uh Echo you got anything
sits something about a firecracker
earlier like a firecracker scenario or
whatever and you were like oh you got
the firecracker like right off the bat
or something like that was it like that
was a big name it was a nickname for an
area in ramadi that was north of Route
Michigan
and there was this little road that
wrapped up and around it was called
firecracker and the reason it was called
firecracker was because there was a lot
of bad [__] going on here there was a
lot of fire a lot of fire cracking on
them as you said yeah interesting okay
and that was like your first that was
our first uh operation in uh ramadi dude
that's a welcome to ramadi situation
right there damn yeah it was good that
was good
still ain't freaking crazy anything else
Steve any closing thoughts
no that's it right old man well uh
thanks for coming on man yeah
oh you know what I'll say one more thing
at one point probably you were like six
months out from retiring and you said uh
I have three courses of action for what
I'm gonna do when I get out
Echelon front Echelon front Echelon
front and I was like right old man
freaking awesome uh which is a ripoff
from the Marine that I covered the book
on the podcast where when he was getting
ready to graduate from
the basic school and they had to fill
out what they wanted to do and this was
in 1967. they had to fill out what they
wanted to do in the Marine Corps and he
put one two three infantry platoon
Commander infantry platoon Commander
infantry platoon Commander it's like
that's what I'm gonna do I was like
Roger that all right I guess we're going
to execute on this thing so it's
freaking awesome thanks for what you did
to the teams for the teams obviously for
America obviously and and
and for freedom and I know we had an
awesome time working together in the
past I've I still I just when I drive at
night whenever I drive at night
especially out here in California in the
desert I'm always thinking of driving
back from from the desert from our
desert training facility and just with
just totally amped because I wouldn't be
able to sleep because I'd be so fired up
for the teams and for the boys and I'd
be like just amps driving back knowing
that we made some freaking guys ready
for war so it was awesome working with
you then and uh awesome working with you
again right now man yeah hey I really
appreciate it I'm glad to be on with
with us along front it's uh it's awesome
can I say one thing real quick yeah hey
I'd like to thank my wife Allison she's
put up with me for all these years she's
prior military good Southern girl from
Arkansas
um and she runs a tight game she keeps
me in she keeps me in line so I love her
with all my heart she's an awesome
person and uh my kids I love you guys
right on man awesome
well uh Echo yes sir
speaking of
getting after it speak you're speaking
of being awesome what do you think we
can do to uh
become more awesome to strive strive for
awesomeness at the very least how about
that let's try it there's some podcasts
we did from some ancient warrior shaking
the world shaking the world with your
awesomeness
well you know that's a that's a big step
go ahead striving to shaking the world
like that's that's kind of a big step
for sure so let's start with striving
cool good all right well hey in your
path to strive for awesomeness or in the
event that you're just straight up
trying to shake the world with
awesomeness Hey look
you might need some supplementation okay
let me let me start this by at Steve you
know you listen to the podcast yes
um
how often do you listen to this part of
the podcast what percentage of time
I I'm probably 50 50 you hang on oh hang
on or is it just you can't hit stop on
your freaking iPhone so you just have to
roll with it it's like stuff there's so
many new products coming out you've got
to listen to it to kind of go all right
is there some new line coming out here
I'm not tracking oh yeah it's true he
makes it good so so he's saying 50 my
guess is he's kind of rounding up to be
nice because you know he doesn't want to
be like harsh to Echo that's cool all
they need is one percent that's right
man he's over here at 50. shoot that's
49. here's what I know I just got a text
from JP and uh and uh Dave Burke they
want to know if you're gonna talk about
their discipline go some Sour Apple
sniper you mean good deal Dave good deal
Dave okay JP just just tracking on it
yeah like tracking that Steve's here and
then sending taking the time to send a
text to say hey make sure you talk about
Sour Apple sniper okay Dave wants to
make JP Jello so you got to mention
Dave's uh After Burner orange okay no
problem we're on it fully so these two
guys are just freaking in the game
that's all man that's hell and I dig it
either way before we get to the
discipline or discipline go which are
you know they're kind of different but
kind of the same we're gonna talk about
joint supplements
it's important because you don't want to
think about this kind of stuff while
we're trying to what shake the world
with you know we're thought or whatever
you know you don't think about your
joints you don't think about your
immunity getting sick all this kind of
stuff so you take these supplements
joint Warfare joints super krill oil
joints
vitamin D3 immunity and General Health
by the way
vitamin D3 is good for a lot of stuff
all kinds especially at this moment in
time in particular we're talking about
factual affirmation about the glory of
the vitamin D
true absolutely true also a cold war
immunity supplement keep those in mind
so you don't have to keep the other
stuff in mind well yeah that's what I
you've you've finally gotten through to
me it's only taken 260 episodes
of uh now I understand that you're like
oh it's good to to not have to think
about your joints bothering you yes
that's a good thing that is a good thing
so now I understand you we don't want to
wake up and be like I hope my joints
hold up today and don't work out or
whatever you see what I'm saying yes you
just want to go into the workout warm up
as they say exactly right also we have
some limit called discipline to
supplement
for your brain for your body for your
whole thing really life your life man
your life powder
take discipline powder instead of coffee
try that good it could be something
that's what I'm saying as far as the
routine also discipline go which are and
or should I say were capsules to begin
with they are capsules if you're on the
go see what I'm saying yes you did that
they're they're very popular at Echelon
front yeah hey can I see something on
the discipline go capsules hey so I've
been using that stuff and so when I'm
going in and I'm doing a speak
engagement that's why they're so popular
now I take two yeah and here's the deal
like when I'm communicating when I'm not
taking that stuff it's like I'm going
down the highway and I I really have to
think hard about the words I'm going to
communicate it's like the the words are
in off the a shoot off a street when I'm
on the discipline go the words are right
there on the road I'm going 60 miles an
hour you're like boom boom boom clerican
size Communications and I don't know
what's in it but it definitely clears up
your mind it clears up your mind it
works you got to get I'm telling you if
you're a boss you got some things going
on a meaning a high speed meaning you're
talking to people it helps I promise you
it helps I wouldn't I wouldn't say it if
it did yeah no that's why that's why at
Echelon front where we get up and we
have to not only we have to speak but we
gotta take questions interpret questions
we got to come up with answers and
solutions and so the team is always like
yeah yeah I'm gonna I want to bring the
a game right yep how do you ensure you
bring the a game take a little
discipline go yeah
and then if you have like a little more
time or maybe you want to enjoy that a
little bit more
you can get a can of discipline go yes
which is what you mentioned right many
flavors now shoot the flavor roster
getting big over here
so most recently afterburner orange good
deal Dave Burke boom before that
sour apple sniper JP Danelle what are
they competing with each other
there's some competition before that
Jocko Palmer which by the way which by
the way Jocko Palmer
Jocko Palmer is not Jaco Palmer what it
is is it's 50 50 iced tea lemonade
that's what it is yeah some people were
thinking it was pomegranate because we
also have Jocko pomegranate white tea
yeah which which you probably remember
Steve yeah
tell us about that's the origin story
right there at an island me rolling into
those briefs with that big old plastic
uh uh uh protein Shaker with freaking
with with pomegranate tea which I would
get from wherever and then I'd just sit
there in the front row and they'd give
the brief and Jack just taking notes
all right
you give your points or actually like
you know whatever the the front line
instructors would give their points then
you'd give your points and then be like
you'd be like you got anything boss and
I'd be like oh
yeah so speaking of caffeine and just a
little bit yes Jocko Palmer that was the
one before that and then before that was
what
who's the first signature oh Dax Savage
the first signature was back Savage yeah
Dakota tasty yeah is that your go-to
what's your go-to
I like the Dax Savage and I like the
story behind Dak Savage yeah dude he's a
monster if you can just get a little if
you can have a little bit of mentality
of Dakota then you're you're a whole
your whole being is better yeah no
offense to JP and Dave I don't have
their mentalities too but let's face it
it's Dax Savage it's freaking Dakota
we're kind of in the game Dakota's kind
of take do what do you did you drink Dr
Pepper when you were a kid I did not
because that's kind of the yeah it's
kind of the flavor apparently it's tasty
yeah it's tasty yeah that's my that's my
wife's favorite yeah which what do you
think of that Dakota I see you tracking
on my life
tracking on my wife Dakota
uh yeah so that one's kind of a sour
apple sniper is
I'm gonna say if you have a little bit
of a sweet tooth probably sour apple
snipers your go-to
that's true Jocko Palmer is is if you
like iced tea and lemonade yeah that was
my favorite before the orange the orange
is your favorite it's currently my
favorite yeah yes sir but hey man you
know to each their own and you know
we're gonna move forward so what this is
though discipline go in a can energy
drink Health Energy drink healthy energy
drink
no healthy drink in the form of energy
drink yeah it's been hard to figure out
what to call it whatever you were just
saying
Steve was pretty legit about just going
down the road finding words
and I'm like yeah dude I know what your
feeling is
yeah and that's what makes like the the
can so good because you know how like
let's face it you're just doing whatever
during the day whatever we do during the
day and you're like oh you know I'll
grab a water I'll grab a juice grab a
soda Sometimes some of us no this this
exactly right though this is like you
can grab it no you don't get the bad
parts of soda yeah yeah you know I mean
yeah if you're going for a water cool
man do it but if you're grabbing like a
Red Bull or I shouldn't say any
particular brand but if you're grabbing
a soda or an energy drink I'm just
saying you're going to pay a price for
that you're paying a price you're paying
a price with your health yeah and with
this discipline goal you would think you
would think that somebody would have
already made an equivalent right you
would think you'd think that it's real
obvious hey I'm gonna make something
that makes you enhances your performance
but it's actually good for you you'd
think somebody would have done that why
didn't they do it number one cost too
much and now they're now they're not
making they're not maximizing profits at
the freaking cash register yeah yeah
that's true and number two is hard yeah
it was hard to do because we had to
instead of just throwing a bunch of
chemicals in there so it wouldn't go bad
we had to pasteurize it which no one
does no so there you go and not only
that hey well how are you going to make
it taste good well we'll just put a
bunch of chemicals in there that that
are bad for you but it'll make people
taste good and we don't care about the
people that we're serving this to so
we'll just let them drink poison
we'll just let him drink poison what did
we do we said no I was like no we're not
doing that we're gonna sweeten it with
something real it's monk fruit so that's
why it doesn't even that doesn't seem
like a lot of barriers to entry right
like Hey we're gonna pasteurize it we're
gonna put we're gonna sweeten it
naturally we're gonna only put healthy
ingredients in it you'd think that those
those bars to entry aren't that high
you'd think someone would have done it
but they didn't yeah they didn't do it
so we did amen like I said now everyone
else can get in line sure as far as
getting in line goes for sure also
speaking of tasting good Mulk
Superior protein in the form of a
dessert so you know
um you know it's such a good dessert
yeah very much so so uh Brad I don't
even know if I'm supposed to say this
but Brian sends my son and me I'm more
of a secondary thing but since my son
Mulk bars oh yeah right I don't know if
they're still in the experimental stage
or whatever the version that you're
getting right now is pretty close to a
done deal yeah yeah so it's like it's
one of those things where yeah man if
you want a dessert like Mulk is the
dessert and it's super as far as like um
you know how like sometimes you're like
oh I need a dessert but I you know I'm
on the path so I'm gonna have a dessert
substitute or something like this what
I'm saying you had those out I thought
those were out already that was the bars
yeah I was eating something back in uh
December last year we were we were in
the experimental phase well they were
taste events yeah they've gotten better
whoa they've gotten better so it's been
hard man it's been really hard there's a
no it's the same it's the same kind of
battles you're fighting with the like
with with making the drink and how do
you actually keep it stable there's more
there's there's well not more but
there's different things in play trying
to make a bar how do you keep it stable
how does it maintain its texture over
time what happens when it's sitting on
the shelf for two months there's a bunch
of things to deal with so we find the
version that you're getting right now
Echo we finally figured out how to
overcome all that and do it naturally
and make it taste good and have the
right flavor profile and stay stable on
the Shelf so it's been a long road it's
been a road that we almost backed away
from and you know me I'm not one to
d-o-r-d-o-r-s this way
sure yeah but either way yes milk
protein informative dessert not a
dessert substitute by the way just
simply dessert straight up where do you
get all this stuff
originmaine.com
originally originally it's many other
places to get it but before we go there
okay let's go here chocolate white tea
you mentioned the pomegranate white tea
chocolate white tea that is available
we're not just talking about Jocko used
to drink white tea now he doesn't huh
drinks even better white tea
yeah remember you still drink it in that
big jar so bring the big juice
back in the day like a crazy person yeah
yeah nonetheless yes that's available as
well at origamaine.com also at the
Vitamin Shop offline
go get it also the discipline go cans
are at Wawa in Florida currently yeah
and by the way if you live in Florida
and you've been and look I I asked and
said hey please this is the mission we
wanna we wanna go into the full chain of
Wawa we needed to go hard in Florida we
needed to go in there and clear shelves
well you all that have been clearing
shelves thank you keep going we're on
the path to Victory don't let up that's
true keep getting after it
because you know why because people in
Pennsylvania and New Jersey and Maryland
they're they're counting on Florida it's
all eyes on Florida we got a rock and
roll in Florida we're on the right path
don't let up
it's true and that the thing is again I
said this before it's kind of a big deal
though to go and get like an energy
drink or whatever and it'd be legitimate
healthy for you this guy's a huge deal
when you I like you don't even really
have to think about but but you just
went you just went back I mean we were
talking about that 15 minutes ago but
we're talking about it again that's cool
I don't think I've I capitalized not
capitalized I broke down the entire
thing about the bars and the thing we
got to do and how hard it was yeah but
that wasn't good enough but not about
the price you pay when you when you take
drink energy drink or a soda or
something like this that price you pay
versus the price that you don't pay
that's a big deal I didn't think I
maximized the uh how should I say the
communication of that big deal check I
think I have no okay
also at originmaine.com is American-made
stuff Jiu Jitsu stuff geez rash guards
some uh some Athletics let me ask you a
question can you wear a ghee when you go
to the grocery mart
[Music]
yeah well as far as grocery Marts go
yeah sure I mean you could technically
advisable well you know I'm I'm not
going to sit here and advise that but
man if you're gonna do it go ahead do
that
okay was there something that we could
wear that would be more acceptable sure
like what maybe some jeans ah there we
go there we go maybe I don't know but
maybe yeah so where can you get
American-made jeans you know it's very
hard
um well how should I say as far as
options go there are not as many options
as you know one might hope but
thankfully yes I am here to tell you at
originmate.com you can get American-made
denim jeans you know what you probably
are thinking if you're an American
you're probably thinking about like
iconic
I'm gonna say three words iconic
American genes and we all know there's a
few brands that fall into that category
they've been around for a long time
iconic American genes I got news for you
your iconic American genes they're not
American
they're not American brutal
so if you want to get iconic American
jeans I'll tell you where you go you go
to originmaine.com and you get yourself
some iconic American jeans we're
bringing them back yes sir
yeah good work they're doing some good
work over there at origin
speaking of good work Jocko has a store
it's called Jocko store obviously so
jogglestore.com that's where you can get
your discipline equals Freedom shirts
hoodies hats a bunch of stuff on there
really cool stuff in my opinion see if
it's your opinion too jungle store.com
oh also we do have a t-shirt Club
kind of creative can you come up with
something else to call this besides
t-shirt club uh yeah okay please I have
that capability sure
I don't know t-shirt platoon
t-shirt Brigade
t-shirt gang we'll just say see what I'm
saying you rolled right into this it's
something that like you know my 11 year
old daughter has a Roller Skating Club
right you see where I'm going with this
tighten yourself up bro
hey it's a working title and we're doing
our best over here nonetheless this is
what it is
the subscription based situation where
you get a shirt new shirt
every month creative designs anyway
check that one out too if you're
interested boom do that good for a gift
too by the way
there you go jocostore.com also
subscribe oh wait wait we have
other podcasts
you didn't even mention this podcast
well we're on this podcast okay we do
have other podcasts oh guess what the
podcast you're listening to it's a
podcast it exists yeah we already know
that we don't got to mention that okay
so yeah uh yeah subscribe to all these
different podcasts Jocko podcast Jocko
unraveling podcast grounded podcast and
Warrior kid podcast check those out
leave a review sure because they're
funny if you leave a review make it
entertaining yeah put some layers in it
it's appreciated yeah
Past reviews have been pretty impressive
you know what I haven't done for a while
is read reviews like online or reposted
I gotta do that those are awesome it's
true I'll do some of that also also we
have a YouTube channel
uh video versions podcast you know you
want to see what Steve Ward looks like
handsome guy I would say who's as far as
handsome guys go but nonetheless if you
want to see it thank you Echo and you're
welcome of course but nonetheless yes
and we have some excerpts on there you
wanna you know watch slash listen to
those uh that's where that's what you
can get on the YouTube channel official
by the way
we got it YouTube Boom also
psychological warfare if you don't know
what that is it's an album Jocko's album
with tracks not music album not yet not
yet we're working it yes boy
anyway it's an album with tracks of
Jocko helping you through a moment of
weakness like we're gonna skip the
workout there's a little track on there
to help you not skip the workout put
simply that's what it is
flipsidecampus.com speaking of Dakota
Meyer he's got a a company where he
prints cool stuff to hang on your wall
that's all you need to say check that
out flipsidecamvas.com got a bunch of
books we talked about one of them today
we talked about a couple of them today
but
about face by Colonel David hackworth
highly recommended
there's a new version that has a forward
in it written by me
how freaking stoked I was to do that man
that's awesome did I tell you that how
that happened no they were so it started
selling again kind of like when I
started talking about it all the time
and so they eventually pulled the thread
and tried to figure out why it was
selling and they eventually figured out
was selling because we were talking
about all the time on the podcast and
um
they wrote me and said hey do you want
to write we're going to re-release it do
you want to write a blurb for the back
which is like a little quote like hey
this is a great book and I wrote them
and said uh I'll write can I write a
forward to it and they'd be like you
want to write it for it and I said hell
yeah I'll write a forward to it most
forwards are about 500 Words If you
Google like how long should a book
forward be it should be about 500 Words
my forward for this is five thousand
words yeah it's like a freaking because
I just went off and explained how I
found it what it meant you know all
these the lessons I learned from it and
so yeah it's been it's been awesome so
if you want to check out that book about
face by Colonel David hackworth then go
ahead and check that out also leadership
strategy and tactics Field Manual
so good you what you just had a company
that told you uh what they just said
yeah well we so they had already they
read extreme ownership and their
leadership team has them they have the
dichotomy leadership and I was like hey
do you guys have leadership strategies
and tactics and they one of them
purchased it and they're like yeah
they're inbound we got them for the
whole team you know and the Beautiful
Thing with it is is you got an issue you
can find it in that book with a good
solution and it might not be 100
solution for your situation but you can
take that formulate it and and utilize
it that's the the beauty of that thing
yeah so powerful that's exactly the what
I had in mind when I wrote it was can
you look up in here okay let me go I'm
having a problem with my subordinate
what how do I do what do I do you know
I'm having a problem with people getting
on board with the new plan what do I do
and just be able to look it up in there
find the solution the beautiful thing
about it is you don't even have to tab
it because the answers are up front hey
you're having this issue flip to this
page and in one to two pages you find
your answers you read through it digest
it boom implement it so easy check uh
the code the evaluations the protocol if
you just need some guidance on where to
go look in the military we got told hey
you're slacking a little here you could
do a little better here but we go
through life without an evaluation of
ourselves how you expect to know where
to go get the code the evaluation the
protocol get the discipline equals
freedom field manual new version bigger
picture of my head yes therefore you
know obviously better another 35 or 40
pages of writing in there
yeah
ideal I'm gonna say it I don't like to
throw that out there but kind of an
ideal gift book right it's not just like
oh I went to the bookstore and I
randomly found this book over here
called whatever I was like I got
something with a little substance it's a
little bigger it's a little heavier
looks cool looks cool you could put it
on a table and just have it be there and
if you read it you're doing even better
yes sir what up
so I got this you you give me a signed
copy a few years ago oh Chad I'm just
trying to see what the difference is oh
yeah well the difference is there's
about 40 extra pages of where I wrote
more stuff gotcha more information
so there's that and then also
there's way of the warrior kid four
field manual which is what your kid
wants for Christmas
that's what your kid wants for Christmas
because all these lessons that we talk
about look you can learn them when
you're 40. after you read freaking
leadership strategy and tactics or you
can learn them when you're seven
and you can go through life
understanding these things and you can
end up in a much better place so what do
you do with your kid
you're going to put them on a path to
mediocracy mediocrity are you gonna put
your kid on a path to being average are
you going to be put your kid on a path
to blame other people and be a victim
their whole life or are you going to put
them on the path to be a warrior kid and
step up
I'll tell you what I recommend way the
warrior K4 Field Manual go ahead and get
some of that also way the warrior kid
one two and three
Mikey and the dragons oh you know what
kids have to deal with being afraid
and it's not just kids but why not learn
at a young age how to overcome fear
get Mikey and the dragons and also
extreme ownership and the dichotomy of
leadership
the OG books
did I say OG yes sir yes I did we also
have Echelon front
it's our leadership consultancy
it's Steve's with us now on the team how
long have you been on the team for March
officially March I've been yeah yeah
ever since I got up and kind of Shadow
and Dave and uh some of the crews so so
if you wanna if you if you want to work
with us if you want help aligning your
leadership if you want to learn the
lessons that we learned if you want us
to come in and help your leadership get
aligned help find where the friction
points are
help figure out where you can be more
efficient as a team
go to echelonfront.com we solve problems
through leadership we also have EF
online which is where we solve problems
through leadership online and we're on
there all the time
so if you if you want to if you want to
come on there and you want to ask me a
question you want to ask me a question
you might think uh how could I ever ask
Jocko question he's easy you go to EF
online you can ask me a question I'll be
sitting right there you want to ask
Steve a question about how he handled a
certain situation how he organized
platoons how he put teams together how
he handled these leadership challenges
go on to EF online.com and you can ask
Steve a question he's literally be
sitting there
so check that out EF online.com we have
the muster we're scheduling the muster
for 2021 go to extreme ownership.com for
details we have EF OverWatch if you want
people that understand these principles
to come and work at your company go to
efoverwatch.com and we have people that
were transitioning from the military to
the civilian sector
and they'll come to your company and
work and if you want to help service
members
active and retired service members their
families gold star families around the
world check out Mark Lee's mom Mark
Lee's mom's organization
Mama Lee she's got a group called
America's Mighty Warriors and if you
want to donate or get involved then go
to America's Mighty Warriors dot org
and if you
let's say you just desire anguish and
pain in your life
in your own life we can give it to you
if you want it we can give it to you if
you want more of my mundane discourse
or you need more of Echoes unfathomable
phraseology
then you can find us on the interwebs
on Twitter
on Instagram which Echo only refers to
as the gram and on Facebook Echo is at
Aqua Charles and I am at Jocko willink
where you at Steve
I'm at Steve Ward 194. Steve Warren 194
or whatever on Instagram on Instagram at
Instagram steve.org 194. is that all
works at answering what do you post
don't know do you post anything
so I probably will here soon it's
Haunting season have you posted have you
posted anything uh no what are you
hunting for ducks hell yeah right on
it's fun yeah
and it's good living
good living not as good eating because
elk or deer but you're gonna get what
you can get what we can get check uh
yeah Steve man thanks for coming back on
it's coming on it's freaking awesome and
uh appreciate everything everything man
yeah everything and
thanks to all of our other military
personnel
right now out in the world on watch
as Steve said you you all are smarter
and stronger and faster and more well
equipped and better trained than we ever
were so thanks for uh holding it down
make sure you train up the people
underneath you
and for our police and law enforcement
firefighters and paramedics and EMTs and
dispatchers and correctional officers
and Border Patrol and Secret Service and
all First Responders
well thanks for protecting us here at
home and to everyone else out there you
know Steve talked a lot today about
setting a good example modeling
the right example
and you'll also notice that almost every
phase of his life he talked about
learning
and how he learned
well I would say that's part of that
good example is don't ever stop learning
don't ever stop growing don't ever stop
trying to improve
you can only do that if you stay humble
so stay humble
listen learn and lead and also
make sure
that you keep getting after it
and until next time this is Steve and
Echo and Jocko
out